what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
[Music]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys sign up for our
memberships to be involved in the chat
the second half of the show we've also
started a facebook page and a twitch
page that are in the description we also
have a new recruiter so if you want to
come on the show and you are in
london um his instagram is in the
description as well and follow my
instagram it's just.pearlythings and i'm
trying to get to 17 000 on instagram so
you should go follow it if you can
and am i forgetting to plug anything-ish
i think oh and all super chats will be
read so if you want to say anything
during the sprint stream super chat it
and i will read it
okay guys so today i have a lovely panel
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age
where you're from and your relationship
status
okay my name's liam
from the gym rat pack
fully
in a relationship
um yeah i'm from east london
local
localed
i'm megan i'm from south london
my relationship status is single
i'm ola i'm 21
i'm from southeast london and i'm also
single
i'm jennifer i'm 53 originally from east
london now in coventry
okay so today
we are
going to be reacting to something that
kevin samuel said before he passed so um
when kevin sam and this is rest in peace
kevin samuels um yeah so
great man great man but this is
something that he said before he passed
away that when he passed had a lot of
people in uproar so we are going to
react to the clip if you could pull it
up-ish
and give our thoughts okay
so i'm going to show it to you guys on
my phone because
but if you have made it to 35 years old
and you're unmarried
you are a leftover woman
a left over woman you are what is left
men know that there is something likely
wrong with you whether you want to hear
it or not i'm going to just go there
with you i'm telling you the truth that
you don't want to hear men know that
there is something likely wrong with you
but you cannot be
fit in
an adjustable six or higher 35 unmarried
something wrong with you
that's where men automatically coming at
it and here's the thing
just like when you were between the ages
of 18 and uh 25 and you didn't want to
settle
you were trying to get them you were
trying to get the ceo the pilot the
investment banker you were trying to get
fluid out
here's what's going to happen if you are
a woman 35 plus
[Music]
and you want a man that's uh
on the same lifestyle level you're gonna
have to share it
all right what do you think about
sharing to me
okay are we back
yeah okay we're back okay
so um i want to start and give your
initial
thoughts to this video starting with you
and then go around
starting with me
35
you're left over
you're done out here
i i just agree wholeheartedly with what
you're saying oh you disagree no i agree
oh you agree you just agree so you think
it's over at 35.35
you know there's all these people
calling themselves tens i'm just curious
how old are you
40. 40. so how was how old would you
date younger
how about would i date yeah yeah
30 30 okay is that is that how old your
girlfriend is no
oh okay my message is my age oh okay
we're big people out here okay
i was just wondering yeah yeah yeah no
worries
okay what about you
um
i personally disagree
um i'm 21 so i don't have that much
experience in like the relation
dating game and everything like that but
i feel like in my generation and like
moving forward
um
i don't think that's possible because
it's like we have people that
are like public figures for example like
just sees an example like kim kardashian
she's like 40 years old
and she's still dating she was in a
relationship like she was married for
like how long and it's like outside of
that you know her breaking up with her
husband and everything
she's still like kind of moving on
still dating i don't think 35 i think 45
is too young for you to say that you're
left over
i feel like that's still a bit too young
but that's just my opinion okay what do
you think
um i don't think i agree with the term
leftover in general
and i also don't think you should put an
age on what your term is left over um i
think it's
i think age is irrelevant i think it's
completely based on who you are
character
all the different other attributes aside
from age like just to say because
someone's a certain age they're left
over women i think that's i completely
disagree completely disagree that's my
stance
i agree
you agree why yeah as a mom and i agree
because most women over 35 who are
single have issues
okay i was
five at one point and i had issues like
you know they've got issues i mean
you're 35.
either
if you're a virgin
i can't understand right or then you're
not left over but if you're 35 and
you've lived life
and you've been through life
why should a man want you i mean
everybody's looking at all these artists
and all these stars
that's not reality that's just one-off
but at 35
i did she was at 35 so i can understand
that if you're not married at 35 or in a
stable relationship has to be something
wrong with you otherwise why aren't you
in a relationship if you're that great
we go ahead what do you guys think um
but in the in the video that we saw he
didn't say relationship i said he said
if you're not married so would you say
it's different if you're in a
relationship
that
if you're good enough to be in a
long-term relationship you're good
enough to get married and if you're not
why ain't you
not everybody aspires to marriage though
that's very true that's the problem
i don't necessarily think it's a problem
i just think that it's a different i
think over the different generations
there's different views for instance a
lot of the women and girls i speak to my
age say they put off marriage and having
children till they're in their 30s so i
think
times have changed in terms of for
instance myself
i would consider
marriage in my 30s like and if i got to
35 and i wasn't married i wouldn't i
wouldn't necessarily see it as a problem
and that there's something wrong with me
um
yeah i see i think just assuming that
there's something wrong with someone
that's not married at 35 is just i think
it's oversimplifying everything
and i completely disagree again
why don't you say though it's it's
if
we wouldn't you want to be married if
there was a guy that checked all your
boxes
would you not would you not want to
marry him
i mean if i feel like if it made sense
then yeah
i don't feel like people should well
firstly i don't think people should rush
into marriage firstly like i feel like
you should that kind of take time when
it comes to that kind of stuff but yeah
like if i have found someone that
literally takes all my boxes and all of
that stuff 100
so then by that logic wouldn't you say
that the the women that aren't picked by
35 like the best guys picked the younger
women and left everyone else over
like in a way
because because if you survey men
between the ages of 20 and 80 and you
ask like what age do they find the most
attractive all of them find that ages
between like 21 to 24 is like a girl's
peak and um 90 of your eggs are gone by
30 and 50 of your options are gone by
30.
i wouldn't say you should say there's a
peak time
i feel like when you're saying there's a
peak time you're basing it on looks
primarily
um i think there's so much more like you
don't marry someone just based on looks
and between the ages of 21 to 24 that
could be your peak but you're finding
yourself so how can you say that okay a
man should pick a woman at that age but
she doesn't even know who she is yet i
feel like when once you put an age on
these things that's where like
divorce tends to come in divorce rates
are so high
i think because you're paying and you're
putting time pressure on it i don't
think there needs to be a time pressure
and sorry going back to your point about
if a guy ticked all my boxes now again i
wouldn't say that i'm ready um because i
feel like i'm still finding myself at
the age of 21.
um you haven't experienced life you
haven't done a lot of things
and
again this is why i don't think aid
should be
the fact what we measure it by because
someone could be 35 and they haven't
experienced life as much as someone
who's
25 and that's a 10 10 year age gap and
they could have had completely different
life experiences so yeah i think
my problem is putting a time on it so in
terms of age i think that's where the
problem is so do you not think it starts
with looks
yeah i think it starts but it will stop
at a certain point like it will not be
long-lasting if it's just based
primarily on looks so the question if
men do would you agree men do value
fertility
like in general men prefer younger women
yeah yeah yeah so what age do you think
it's over
when when would you qualify women as
leftover because at some point like the
guys aren't lining up for girls at 75
right
so so at some point it ends right where
where would you pinpoint that
and i'm curious for you why don't you
guys all give your answers so when you
start
okay
first of all
um
you know oh to be 21.
but
at 21 by the time you reach 55
what have you been doing like say 20. we
start our relationships what did we say
speaking to the mic oh sorry brother
[Laughter]
why did i have to be the first to do
that
but yeah so you start your relationships
from like 16
16 to 35
all them years what have you been doing
you've had ups you've had downs
going back to what you say by then
there's issues there's trauma there's
you know
you're you're
you've been through a lot you've got
certain guards up because you've been
hurt in certain ways you're seeing
similar traits in partners that you saw
in somebody else that's why when i say
at 35
if i if i see you at 35 i'll be able to
recognize
okay this has happened to you that's
happened to you you've put this time
frame on that i don't want to do this
until then and at 35 what's that
geriatric pregnancy so it's high risk
high risk pregnancy so
for men
we have babies until the end of time for
you
from 35 it gets risky it does
so you can say ah you know if i'm single
today which i'm not
but if i was
i'm i
i've got a goal down the spectrum
because i don't want that risk why am i
gonna have a risk or you're 35 you're
gonna have certain baggage
because we all got baggage so but
you know by then it's other people's
stuff that's coming into my relationship
and guess what i don't want it
so by 35 you need to be
more or less
in your stride with someone even if it's
not marriage
even if it's not marriage you shouldn't
be on the market at 35
so i'm not saying you have to be married
but i'm saying you need to be clearly
off the market but that
would you think
um
so
i'm not too sure like
i wouldn't class people being that's
over 35 as a leftovers that's i feel
like that's a bit of a
kind of
a return but um
i feel like
regardless regardless of the age you're
still going to have like
you're still going to go through [ __ ]
like in life you're always going to go
through stuff
me personally i would like for me to be
like in a stable relationship which i
don't feel like i'm ready for right now
i'd want to be like
stable with myself like mentally like
and before i bring that to someone else
because like if i'm in a relationship
with someone and it's now becoming a and
i come with all my baggage that's going
to cause issues in a relationship if i'm
not secure
um in terms of
the age i would consider
i don't know
i don't really know because then like
like you said people that are like 70
plus years old no one's really
i mean very few probably but like
i don't know and then at the same time
as well you we did say like looks kind
of
you start with like yeah
there's people that are 35 that don't
look favor
there is that so one side no okay just
one quick question have you you've been
in a relationship before yeah yeah
and it's affected you
no i'm not saying negative or positive
i'm just saying this affected you it's
changed the course of why you've decided
i'm just finding me i'm doing this so 15
years of that
i find you in 15 years time have gone
through that
all right let's say
three or four times
that's
nobody really wants
what you're gonna come with
because you would have done it many
times
and you haven't figured it out
you haven't self-diagnosed yourself and
found out what what you need to do so
that's why i say at 35 it's different
when you're young
you know but if you keep
and i'm not i'm not saying this to you
we're just having a conversation but um
just in general if you keep doing the
same thing and getting the same outcome
by the time
we meet
i'm 40 you're 35 i'll be like ma
this is just like bad luck
four times
and i'm saying four times because i'm
being respectful
i'm saying four times because i'm being
respectful yeah can i just say that
you're saying about 35
but if you are young wouldn't it be
easier to be in a stable relationship
get married when you're young when you
haven't got that trauma yes you haven't
got that experience so as far as i'm
concerned the younger you can get
married the better because you're saying
like oh you've got you've got to do this
you might have to do travelling you
might have to do this you have to do
that you have to do this and do that by
the time you're 35
who wants you you've done everything who
wants you
you've got to feature yourself
you're looking at all these stars
but what have you got to offer a man at
35 when you've been for everything
you've done everything you've got all
this history behind you you've got all
this trauma wouldn't it be easier while
you're young
to get your head together and just say
right but i'm gonna find someone same
level as me i'm gonna get married the
early the better
no trauma
both enjoy the experiences together
learn together grow together by the time
you're 35 you've done everything and
a man's gonna look at you and think what
am i doing with her when i can go and
get somebody younger
okay so i feel like i have a lot of
problems with a lot of things you said
one thing is you kind of made the
assumption that um
you don't have you won't you can't get
trauma from a marriage like he said
one a positive from marrying early is
that you don't have trauma you can have
trauma from your childhood
like i wouldn't say that you should just
equate being young with not necessarily
having any problems haven't experienced
life
and another thing i would say is
again i feel like marriage is a huge
commitment that shouldn't be undermined
like once you've married someone you're
committed to them like what they want if
they wake up tomorrow and they decide
they want to move across the world that
impacts you and those kind of things
those tendencies are more likely to
happen when you're young
and you don't really you're still trying
to figure out life
so i would agree i would disagree with
oh you should
aim to marry early
so i have a question do you think that
what do you think is more traumatizing
one partner or
what would you say the average body
count well i was being generous yeah
okay
okay so
so let's say like by like 35 right how
many partners would that girl have had
over the years like what's more
traumatizing one
or
okay so this is another problem you
can't equate someone's quality and who
they are to their body count like so so
this is this is a common misconception
that a lot of girls have and the reason
you can is because if a girl's a virgin
on her wedding night she has an 80
chance of a happy marriage if she sleeps
with five or more guys it goes down to
25
and the women that sleep with more men
they they have higher rates of
depression
okay so again you're quite i feel like
it depends on the person again because
you're with what you just said i feel
like you're seeing the quality of the
quality of a marriage as being
like primarily linked to how the sexual
life is and i think there's so much more
to marriage than just that okay what do
you mean by that because we're talking
about marriage we're not talking about
our relationship like i would say the
difference between marriage and
relationship is your life is literally
like intertwined with that person's life
in a marriage whereas in a relationship
it's not necessarily to that extent like
it's i wouldn't say a relationship you
can't put a relationship or marriage on
the same scale because the commitment is
completely different in both so i feel
like with what you're saying and what
we're discussing we have to be careful
that we're not
we're not confusing marriage with
relationship because i think they're so
very different no i'm not confusing
marriage with relationships i'm talking
about sexual partners so that that
doesn't even necessarily mean she got
them in a relationship okay so so what
i'm saying is the more women are the
more men that a woman sleeps with she
has a lower and lower chance of getting
a happy marriage and there's higher and
higher rates of depression that are
linked to that
so what i'm saying is by the time a
woman is 35
i i don't know how many partners she's
probably had but i would guess it's more
than five
so so
she's going to go through relationship
after relationship after relationship
maybe casual maybe serious of it not
working out
i don't know i feel like
again
we shouldn't make assumptions because
you could be 35 and your body counts
less than five
so what would you say is the case there
i would say that's an exception it's not
the rule based on data so they survey
women about what their body counts are
and
i you know you don't know if they're
telling the truth or not but like but
like self-reported data that tends to be
higher the older they get so like you
can look at like virginity numbers and
like the older they get the less women
are virgins and you can assume
like you can infer from that they
continue to have sex
can i just say something she's saying
about relationships and marriage i think
that's the problem because the same way
how
committed you're supposed to be in
committed relationships that lead to
marriage and i think sometimes you only
learn that with age because so many
people are having relationships that
they feel well i don't have to commit to
them because i'm going to remember that
person anyway if you're not going to
marry the person why are you in a
relationship with him what is your end
goal so if your end goal is not marriage
why are you in that relationship
and the same way how you think that oh
yeah you could only be committed to each
other when you're in marriage
well that is what a perfect relationship
if that's what makes a relationship last
long
is when you're committed as if you were
married
that's what leads to marriage so if
you're in a relationship and you think
oh it's just a relationship i'm not
going to be committed because we're not
married to me that's a failure that's
when you're going to end up hitting 35
and just being left over that's i feel
like you misunderstood me because i
completely agree with you on that point
in terms of
i don't think that you should be in a
relationship if you don't like i don't
see the point of dating if it's not
leading to marriage but being realistic
with the generation i'm in
not a lot of people are dating not a lot
of people like at 21
and not a lot of people are thinking
about marriage even if they are in
relationships
they're not seen and it differs
sometimes it's the woman that tends to
be seen at um
acquainting a committed relationship to
lead into marriage but with men
that's not necessarily always the case
so
yeah i do agree with you on that point
however there is a difference between a
relationship and marriage
have you ever heard of the pareto
principle when it comes to dating
so if you ask a hundred percent of women
what they want in a guy they list 20 of
men
and sometimes it's less sometimes it's
15 sometimes it's 10 sometimes it's 5 so
the reason women will say things like
men are trash is because we've all been
dating the same guys
and and so a common misconception is a
lot of these guys aren't looking to
settle down and those guys aren't
because they get
they get their choice why would they
settle down when they get their choice
of a bunch of women on birth control
but if if you date older and you don't
go for the top 20 of guys a lot of guys
are looking for something serious
but something serious doesn't
necessarily mean marriage
i will say i think a lot of men are
scared of getting married because the
laws don't favor them
yeah i've got a question for you you
said you you're not looking to get
married right i didn't no i didn't say
that i didn't say i would say right now
like it's not on my mind right now okay
um all right and so it was more so that
do you see
do you think that marriage is
advantageous to the woman
or do you think it's an equal stance for
both men and women
because
i i asked this question because it
sounded like
you
were saying
me women don't really sometimes they
don't want to get married but it's like
do you understand that women
would should want to get married because
the benefits are so much in their favor
i i didn't say that women don't want to
get married i feel like they
like in my generation they tend to want
to get married a bit later in terms of
because another thing that i've gained
from this conversation is that we're
kind of equating marriage with that's
when people are planning to have
children so
a lot of women that i've spoken to my
age they want to establish their careers
first and have that stability
financially before entering marriage and
then having a child but i wouldn't say i
think
i would say that there are both
advantages and disadvantages for women
in marriage however
it depends on the type of woman you are
because i do feel like once a woman is
married she loses
some
power
and some control
um
yeah do you disagree with me
kind of i don't think a marriage should
allow a woman to kind of lose control
but more so
i don't know like i i don't think she
loses control
she may be submissive if that's what you
see as losing control then okay i
understand that i think in relationships
there's always going to be sacrifices on
both sides like you like for example
like
when you're single you're going to act a
different way as a guy or a girl then
you are going to be in a relationship
yeah but
it's like the the benefits almost
outweigh the cost because the power
shifts a lot to women when we get
married
how so
so um women are the ones that are
leaving relationships it's not men
like they file for divorce 70 to 80 of
the time if you're college educated it's
a 90 chance so women are the ones that
are leaving
and if you if you have a kid with a guy
you're entitled to in the uk i want to
say
18
of
18 of his income
and so that's why that's why a lot of
men are afraid of getting married is
because like it's
the cost is so great if you get divorced
like that's 20 of your income that's a
lot
so
but on the other hand you have like
legal protections as a girl
so it's like the the power shifts i'm
not saying it's right i'm just saying
that's how it is
kind of just i just think it's all about
the examples that you have of a marriage
because
whenever i hear young people talk about
marriage it always sounds so
down you know i can't have enough fun
you know i can't you know i've gotta
give up everything can sometime in the
future kind of like oh yeah i will one
day and there's nothing wrong with being
submissive everybody all the women see
submissive a bad thing it's not a good
thing if you've got a man leading you
you know a marriage for a woman
is great she's got nothing to lose she
can go in with nothing and she can come
up with everything so as far as i'm
concerned it's just like
if you've got a good example of marriage
then you will see marriage is a good
thing
and all around yeah
good examples of marriages
you know because my mom and dad were
married i got my mom and dad look great
i had some old people that were married
they were great i remember i saw this
woman and she was like well spoken
and she was married to this man who had
money and they've been together for
years
and she said i said how do you do it she
said compromise
she goes look at him look at him and she
was all well to do and he was there at
the bar drinking she goes you know and
she'd actually helped him put his money
away to retire and marriage is a great
thing i think sometimes it's the
examples that people see around them
that tarnishes it to make it sound like
you're gonna lose everything because
there's people out there with marriages
that travel together have fun together
it's not about i'm gonna get married to
have children is i'm going to get
married to be committed to this person
then we grow together and children will
come do you think just quickly that
the options
that young people have now
has made that more difficult
too many too many options
because there was a time where
you know it's in your local area you
know the
you go to church or wherever you go and
someone knows somebody and now it's
worldwide well i think the development
of birth control changed the game
because there used to be consequences so
if you slept around like you likely
would get pregnant
where then you could just sleep with
whoever you wanted
and so if you look at it's really
interesting if you look at
graphs of when the divorce rate started
to go up in the western world it's it's
like the same as when birth can like the
number of women on birth control role of
tomassi tweeted it if you want to go to
his twitter it's actually really
interesting
because men can't get pregnant yeah well
and then that gives that that's that's
why women um push off marriage later and
later gives them more time to lock down
like the high value guy
and and that's the other thing is like
girls think they're hotter than they are
in 2022 because a girl that's a four
five six or seven can sleep with a guy
that's an eight nine or ten but he would
never be seen in public with her he's
just he's just sleeping with her
yeah and so that's what i'm saying like
because girls will think their level is
the guy that they're sleeping with but
it's not it's the guy that you can get
to commit to you so that then you have
girls that are
shooting down the guys that are actually
on their level
and so it leads this that's why it's 50
of women over 30 are single and
childless
then they try to go back to the guys
that were on their level yeah that and
then you men don't want them yeah yeah
because that's why they're left behind
they're with someone of on their level
yeah yeah and i'm curious because um
you're a bit older so
what like what
i'm just curious what are you you're
familiar with red pill it seems like
do you see that that
older women get past
how do i put it
they the guys they rejected earlier will
turn them down later yes
it happens a lot
it happens because you see the women and
they think oh no i remember there was a
man and
he was um
he didn't look younger i didn't look all
that nobody was after him he became a
dustbin man you know nobody was after
him and they got older and he got more
handsome and then he got a nice car and
everything everybody's after him you
know why because they realized how much
dust men wanted how much they earned
and then when they were after him he
didn't want them he got some girl you
know he was a dustman i think he married
like a lawyer or something like that
because she saw his worth and it wasn't
how much he earned he was a good guy
with potential but nobody wanted nobody
wanted him at the time
but now all those women now that you
know three children four children
why is man gonna want to take on you
with two three four children you know
over 35 why
and what mistakes do you see did you see
younger girls make
when it comes to dating and what
mistakes maybe did you make and you
learned from
i got pregnant on the pill
oh wow so yeah first time pregnant on
the peel i was on the pill and you never
missed the day
i was only on it for about a month
okay yeah so and
i got one child you know because i
learnt my lesson but nowadays it's like
it's too easy to go and get rid of a
child
it's too easy to go
and say well i'm gonna get birth control
and i'm going to sleep with everyone
because i'm going to i'm not going to
get pregnant it's not going to bother me
but every what the young people don't
realize every time they sleep with a man
you're giving away a bit of yourself
so by the time you've reached 35 there's
hardly anything left to you because
you've given it away to all these people
and they don't realize that men can
sleep with
women i don't mean nothing to them but
women sleep with men and it's emotional
and every time you sleep with a man
you give away a bit of yourself and
that's what the young people don't
realize that they're just giving
themselves away bit by bit by bit do you
think women have gotten better or worse
over time worse why because they just
think they're all that
they're independent
they've got their own money they can do
what they like they don't need men and
then when they need the men the men
don't want them but they do need men
they just don't realize it yet
why does a woman need a man that's what
i mean they just don't realize it yet
because you try surviving on your own
without a man you cannot wake up in the
morning and go through your whole day
without having to rely on a man for
something like what
like everything around them whether you
go you get your petrol wherever you go
and you get the bus whether you the the
the
clothes that you wear in the shop the
designer you cannot get through life
without a man
men built the world
like they they do all of the hard jobs
in society everything that makes the
infrastructure run
i'm not saying we don't need men that's
not my view at all but i just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over i feel like the things you're
saying
and the over reliance on men that's what
perpetuates that view because it makes
it seem like a woman literally can't
survive without a man and i feel like
you're linking that like one thing you
mentioned earlier you said that there's
a link between divorce rates and um when
women were able to get access to birth
control and i feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and
she's gonna take some of the man's
income in that sense i feel like
um
i've lost my point now i forgot what i
said to tell you a lot of i feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think is feeling like how i
can do it what do you think is feeling
no because you say i feel like i feel
like i feel like so i was just wondering
if you're saying that i do want me to
say i know no no i don't know i'm is it
all feeling if you tell me you're
feeling then
i don't think it's feeling this is what
i mean i feel like women have what do
you want me to say
a tough girl's time yeah
okay
so um yeah from what you said about
divorce rates and birth control i feel
like that's where women have gained
power in terms of they don't necess
they're not burdened financially
um so they're free to leave they're free
to leave marriages and i feel like
that's another reason why i said
um
i feel like our generation is changing
so women are we are becoming more
independent because
it's not the same like
no offense but like compared to now and
30 years ago the amount of women are
educated and then
because they're more educated they have
access to higher paying roles
more dirt though they have more dirt
okay okay but that's i would say
what leaves women in
a bad place financially is kids
and because we have access to birth
control now that's what i mean by i feel
like we have power and i wouldn't go to
the extreme of saying a woman needs a
man but i wouldn't also go to the
extreme of saying
a woman can't live without a man i feel
like there's an in between
but you shouldn't use extremes i think
it's extremely easy to say that
all right then if you was young
and then you had a child
and then you said you didn't need the
man you'd be all right raising a child
on your own because you wouldn't need a
man
you just got your child
whereas you might not think that you
need a man when you've got a child but
actually you do but you won't realize
that until you see the consequences for
your life from through your child's life
because when women have children
it's all right to say i'm gonna leave
the marriage because you're gonna leave
the marriage with the child the house
the car his money you don't have to work
again
so when you're saying that women have
the power from like way back when
because i'm the oldest so way back when
in my day
i wanted when i had to go to um
when you go to school and they say what
do you want to do when you grow up and
you go and see the officer two things i
wanted to be
either a housewife or a lorry driver
and she told me those are the two most
stupid things she ever had to come out
that room and all through my life all i
wanted to be was a housewife and all of
my friends thought it was crazy that was
the worst job ever but some of the most
successful couples i know
is with the woman at home because she
the man brings everything in
but
i can see you smiling as a young person
there's nothing wrong being
a housewife and having your side hustle
i wouldn't you can have your side hustle
you can have your own business you can
have your own law firm you can have
everything like that
and still be a housewife and when young
people look at it like oh there's
something wrong with being a housewife
wait till you're 35 and you're on your
own and there's no man and it's just you
and your pets
and then you're gonna think i've got my
degree i've traveled i've done this i've
got my house i've got my business who
are you going to travel with your old
friends
your old female friends because nobody
of any status is going to want to travel
with you especially if you've got
children
so you might think that things were
different back in the day
but things were actually better back in
the day because people got married i am
one person i believe until death do you
part you shouldn't be allowed to get
divorced somebody should have to die
before you get divorced because that's
what it says till death do you part and
if more people were into marriage
thinking you know what get counselling
let me go and do this
talk to my elders talk to my parents
then have more successful marriages and
it wouldn't seem so bad as a young
person
i agree with you i'm not against
marriage i don't have anything against
marriage but i'm just realistic at um in
terms of generation we're in i feel like
that's where a lot of the things you're
saying
i disagree
um
and another thing that i feel like
you're saying you need a man for is when
you have a child which i understand
because parenting is a two it's for two
people it's not for one person
regardless of if you're a man or a woman
you need two people to parent however i
wouldn't say that
a woman needs like what you're saying
about so you're saying a woman that's 35
she's done a lot like in terms of
financially she's had a lot of life
experiences but she's not with a man
you're saying her life is unsuccessful
just because she's not gone i'm not
saying that i'm saying she'd be
successful but will she be satisfied i
won't she'd be lonely or she won't be
lonely what are you going to do when it
comes to 50 and you're on your own 60
when your own 70 when you're on your own
and if you intend to be on your own like
say 35 if you can say right you know
what i'm not going to settle down to my
35 start planning your pension start
planning that when you're old or you're
disabled or you can't manage yourself
who's going to look after you you might
as well start planning these things
ahead because
a lot of people don't look ahead like
that but if you had a husband
and you're married pensions and all them
things so if you're going to be like
enjoying your life now i had my pension
at 18 so i was different i was when
there was early people but you need to
start planning i have a pension early
that's good you need to start planning
early
and think about property and not travel
in and things like that then i can say
well if you're going to be on your own
fine but be happy on your own but can
you be happy on your own at 60 70 80.
and that's the one thing just to back
what she's saying up the least happy
group of women is women over the age of
45 that have that are single and
childless that make over 47 000 per year
but that's not what i'm saying i'm not
advocating for a woman that's childless
and she doesn't have a partner at 40.
i'm just saying just because
you don't have someone at 35 doesn't
mean you keep going to 60 and 70. again
go into extremes i'm 53. that's not
extreme no but you keep mentioning six
talking to your mic talking about you
keep mentioning 60 70
that's extreme from 35. but that's
because you don't you don't go from you
haven't mentioned okay a woman at 40.
you're jumping you're jumping years
that's what i'm saying i'm saying just
because my point is to begin with just
because you're 35 and you're single
doesn't mean you'll be single at 40 at
60 at 70. but the problem is at 35
you've lost all the things that men
value that that's the problem because
men value femininity they value
fertility and they value youth
so you can't say you're youthful when
you're almost halfway through your life
like
you can't say you're fertile when you're
you're you're about to have geriatric
pregnancy so it's like and you look
worse than you did it at 25 right so
you're the way you're thinking is like a
woman and that's that's how a girl
thinks like as a guy that has more
experience that's attractive to us and
that's been through a lot like that's
attractive because it's someone that can
lead us but like men that's just not
what they value
okay i agree with what you're saying
again
but you have to consider that
i think the generation we're in now is
so novel like even us being in this room
sitting together like we're in london
and a lot of us come from different
backgrounds like globalization means
we're all so interlinked like there are
different options we're not just looking
at
primarily looks anymore because again
even looks nowadays is completely
different but women women are men are
men are it starts with looks for men men
are all visual
we are visual are you are you it's true
i'm not saying this or not but
again we're in a different generation
like the amount of people that would
have surgery
to alter their looks would be completely
different to people all those years ago
using the data that you're using so it's
like those looks that you think men are
placing such a high value on
it's not even real well well men can men
can see it so a lot of times like guys
will give sexual attention to girls that
get like bbls and have all the surgeries
and stuff but that's not who they why
you don't want them yeah that's like
that's like the one like you think pete
davidson is trying to wife kim
kardashian come on exactly so are you
talking about men value youth men value
look for long-term women for for
commitment
that's what you're saying for long term
exactly so if if a woman is doing all
these things to make her look more
youthful to alter her looks then that
doesn't necessarily mean that you can do
that at 35 you can go get a bbr at 35
and you can look like you're 20 at 35.
men can see the difference like your
your forehead doesn't move when you get
a bunch of botox like it's like they're
not blind they might it might work out
with an instagram filter but but even
kim kardashian looks weird as hell now
when she talks like this
and your eggs are going to be old yeah
the thing is why would you
i say you're 35 and i can see that
you've had work done and you look great
why do i not want the 25 year old that
hasn't had work done and it's just
again i feel like no i'm just saying
what yeah why why wouldn't i go for her
why would i go what's the difference
no offense but again that's you
um
hold on another guy ish what do you
think
most men would go for the youth youthful
girl why because
we understand that by the time you're 35
there's questions that need to be
answered as to why you haven't got a man
what what did each man see in you
that passed up
a girl that is young beautiful and like
great for a relationship should get
scooped up straight away but by at least
26 25 like that would happen
the moment like you're teetering on
30 35 there's questions that have to be
asked like what what's wrong with this
girl that these guys have gone now i'll
pass or she hasn't been able to stay in
a committed relationship
again i feel like
um
women nowadays
like a lot of what is being said is like
men have the power in terms of picking
and choosing and leaving the
relationship
but yes and just to interrupt you sorry
um women have
acts give access to sex and men give
access to relationships so the power
dynamic
each person has their own it's not as if
like we've got all the power no you give
access to who you allowed to have sex
with and we give access to the
relationship side so in terms of
marriage us putting a ring on you saying
we are committed to you
um i agree i i do agree with what you're
saying in terms of access but
a woman can decide to leave a
relationship as well i feel like that's
what's being
ignored no no
it's not being ignored because we agree
with you you have the power to leave a
relationship that's detrimental to us
yeah that shows a lack of loyalty
so so if you if you have a history of
leaving relationship after relationship
after a relationship the guy is going to
think
oh well if i if i wife her she's going
to leave me too if she left the last
three guys but what was the reason
because i feel like a lot of things are
being ignored for instance if and for
instance one thing you said earlier was
we should marry we should marry early um
and
like you made it seem as if it's all
beneficial for a woman in a marriage but
what about things like domestic abuse so
you're now in a marriage with someone
who they might not have been like that
they might not have been violent at 21
but
things happen
life happens they might become violent
and at 24 they're now violent but you're
tied down with this person in a marriage
why why is that where your mind goes
when that's an exception it's not the
rule like because here's the thing
here's the thing and most abusive
relationships are mutually abusive so
the woman's hitting the man and the
man's hitting the woman and one-sided
abuse actually women do more than men do
so women hit where it's not retaliated
more than men do okay um would you say
though that
in terms of domestic abuse would you say
that that's something that would
happen
in a marriage with an older couple let's
say a couple that married when they were
both in their 40s compared to a younger
couple
no i would say that the men that are
abusive usually the women sees that
pretty early on and just ignores it and
continues to do what she's going to do
so i don't i don't think i think it
actually says something about the woman
too because why are you picking men that
are abusive
i wouldn't i can't i wouldn't say that
you can just tell that somebody's
abusive
i wouldn't say you can tell like you're
saying you're picking a man that's
abusive
but
i can't look at you and say you're not
going to be abusive
but you can look at the red flags or
flags that
would could go there and go oh i'll
ignore it
oh he didn't mean that but if you're if
you're insisting on a woman should just
find someone and settle as early as she
can
then you're you're basically saying she
should compromise with red flags that
could potentially lead to a domestic
domestic abusive relationship no i
didn't say don't vet him
i think you should steal that a guy
i think it takes years to vet someone no
you just go and ask your elders
go and ask the men around you what do
you think of this guy and have them have
a conversation with him have them speak
to him vet him and they will give you
the honest truth about them and that way
you don't have to
even maybe ask me family like find out
like just ask the people the oldest
around you
what do you think of this guy and
they'll give you genuine advice that
will give you
enough
knowledge or information to say i can
pick this guy because usually they've
seen things or they know things from
just looking having conversations that
you may never ever see
i disagree again because
the version of me that i showed my
friends to the version of me i showed my
mom is not the same
so you can't say okay you met different
the elders the family but they may not
know this person
the way he actually is
um and that's one thing i'll say is i'm
not like i'm not experienced in how
domestic abuse relationships work i
can't say that i have experience with it
or i know about it but you i don't think
you can
categorize all men that have those
tendencies in the same way in that
their family would be able to tell for
instance so so i have a question what
percentage of men do you think are
abusive
i don't i don't i don't know do you
think it's a high percentage
another thing is not everything is
reported that's what you have to bear in
mind so you have to take i feel like
when it comes to relationships you can't
just go off like
quantitative data you have to take it
with a pinch of salt because
relationships it's a lot about
experience okay so i'm asking you what
what percent of men do you think are
abusive
i think reported is like a smaller it's
a small percent
right i'm not talking about reported
like what percent do you think are
abusive
um
i don't think that it would be a lot
again it i think it depends on where we
are in the world and
i feel like again
where we are in terms of time
is a unique time
and
it's gonna differ based on
you can give it like plus or ten like
minus ten percent ballpark
because because the point i'm trying to
make is a lot of times as women like we
go to the extremes of where something
can go wrong
well when when we're talking about
getting married younger and then we
think of like the worst possible
scenario that could possibly ever happen
when it's not the rule
okay i just i don't see what the
advantages are to get married earlier
like i don't
i don't you would have to like
show me what are the advantages of
getting married earlier because it's
literally like i'm it's kind of like the
way i see it is similar to having a
child early
because now my whole life is tied to
another person that's how i see it
so it's not in terms of marriage the
concept is wrong it's in terms of i'm
young i don't even know myself to the
extent that i will know myself in a
couple of years and i'm literally tie
myself to another person for instance
with mothers
the mom you would be to your first child
is not the same
the same parenting style you would have
maybe let's say there's a five year age
gap between your next child you wouldn't
be the same mom to your second child
because you've had completely different
life experiences you've learned you've
learned a lot about yourself so how you
would deal with your relationship with
that person would be different that's my
that's my point essentially so do you do
you think do you want to get the best
possible partner that you can get
of course like in terms of like who you
would marry and settle down with
so the point when we talk about getting
married early i'm not saying get married
at 18 right so i think i think there's
some some truth to that like 18 for me
probably be a little too young but what
i'm saying is you're going to have
everything in life's a negotiation right
so if you want to get the best deal you
can younger is better because men prefer
younger women that have lower body
counts
and it's not it's not fun i don't enjoy
that like i'm going to hit 30 and i'm
going to be less valuable to a guy but
it's dishonest for me not to understand
that fact
and so
if you want to get the best quality
partner you can get it's just better to
negotiate when you're younger
okay i do get what you're saying in
terms of that but one thing you said is
the value
that's i feel like that's where i
disagree the most in terms of
the way we see value like what we term
as a valuable woman or as a valuable man
in terms of value like
personally for myself i would say value
in a person i wouldn't want someone that
doesn't
you don't even know what you want in
life you don't know who you are which i
feel like the earlier 20s that's a lot
of what it is well that's but that's a
female lens and it's why women don't
pretend to date guys under 25 they tend
to date guys five to seven years older
so again this is like you're seeing
things from a female point of view like
you want a guy with experience you don't
want a guy who doesn't want to have
himself figured out but a guy on the
other hand they want a girl that's gonna
get on their program
okay i would say again i agree with what
you're saying but um
i disagree with the get with your
program like me personally
i've that's the thing i feel like before
women were with the get with the program
but now women have their own program
right and that's how i see that's how i
see it and that's what i think makes the
difference
in terms of age well i know and that's
why that's why like honestly modern
women are leftover women because they're
either left over from the last guy
or they're left over in their 30s
because we're not the things that men
value anymore
i think sometimes people confuse what
men actually want
they go with their looks and men just
want somebody to risk to have their back
cooked clean and just support them and
peace is that what you're saying that
men want yeah yeah
i'm telling you that's what men want
they don't care about you know it looks
initial yeah it's like can you cook can
you clean can you look after the kids do
i mean do you know how to organize money
if i give you a hundred pounds a day can
you turn it into 200 pounds tomorrow
young woman can do that i'm saying any
woman with the right man that is
determined to have a successful
relationship can do that that is what
the men want men don't want you to go
out you know handbags and makeup and
shoes and that save that for a day out
save that for christmas
men want a woman to have their back they
want you know that bonnie and clyde had
they rolled together that's how i'm
that's what a man wants and
you might say it was a generation thing
back then it's still now and if you ask
if you ask boys young men about your age
around your age what they want
they say oh no that's a woman for now
not a woman forever
what's a woman for now the women that
they're having sex with all the young
girls that right now i mean could you
describe a woman for now what for a
young guy yeah anyone you're sleeping
with men don't care you're good looking
you're gonna sleep with them you're a
woman for now
you could be a woman for an hour for two
years you could be a woman for now for
three years they will sleep with the
same one all the time but you're not
gonna get married because you're not a
woman forever i'll describe it i'll just
grab it so a woman for now might be
considered someone that believes she's
independent she don't need a man
because as a man like if i'm in a
relationship and i don't feel needed
it's like why am i here
but is that not a young woman would you
not say that that that like the
independent that tends to be a young
woman no no
no no no that tends to be the modern
woman
most modern women are younger and i
think it's a i think it's so bad that
women can't see the other side that
society's kind of pushing the narrative
that being an independent is the way to
go
establish your career
um
get married later and you're missing a
trick because what it is is men value
fertility and youth so
your best bet to get the man you want is
to get him between the ages of 21 to 25
because once you look for him older he's
going to be thinking oh i can find you
at a younger age
why would i come for you
so it it's it's a sad truth but that's
just reality but the truth all the thing
yeah yeah i think
the main
like the
the crux of your point i would say rest
on the fertility point like aside from
that
i don't see why a man would want a
younger woman
for a for long term because what you're
saying is because so we're talking about
looks and we're saying that we're
assuming that looks is when you're at
your prime in terms of looks when
between the ages of 21 and 26 and you
said like would that not be a woman for
now that's what i'm saying but if you're
basing it on looks
which you're equating to being young
would that not be a woman for now that's
what i'm saying
so the only other point that you would
go for a young woman is based on
fertility
right because he wants he wants someone
to have kids with yeah that's what i'm
saying that's the only other reason that
you would look for a woman that's young
that's why a lot of girls like the cheat
code as you date guys that are older
because they're more they're looking for
something serious more than guys your
own age yeah that's what yeah but so so
he what he's talking about is the modern
woman mindset where it's me me me me
first
and it's never like i can't compromise
anything in my life for someone else
yeah i would say i disagree that's what
i'm saying
again i don't think we should see as
extremes because marriage is not an
extreme like marriage is based on
compromise
so in terms of the modern woman i was
again i would say the modern woman is an
extreme would you not agree
no i think it's very common i think that
i mean the average age of first marriage
in the uk is 31. i mean in terms of
mindset like entitlement mindset i would
say anyone that waits till 31 to get
married has the modern woman mindset in
some in some regard and they get an
elder
they have some a lot of the older women
that were looking back and thinking i
can be a modern woman at 40 and 45 it's
too late for them but again another
thing with this generation is
we have less kids like families are way
smaller in this generation and that's
another reason like it's linked to that
but
the reason why there's less kids is big
there's less kids but there's not less
sex
because back in the day
the more sex you had the more children
you had yeah but now
that's why you only had back in the day
you only had sex with one person because
you're gonna have kids with them but now
there's less kids
there's more sex because there's
contraception and that's what the men
don't want
so you might say you know what they
might want me because i've not had no
children but you might have
no children but 15 previous partners
and that's the difference
but how would they know that's another
thing like i feel like men talk we
can see anyway i mean the same way when
you're dating you're vetting a woman
you're vetting a man i'm vetting a woman
once you're with them for a while you'll
start seeing even if you never say to me
i was with 15 guys
you'll start seeing little things that
will present this is like they say let a
woman talk she'll tell on herself yeah
yeah
definitely but um and and if you if this
is the guy you want don't you want to be
honest like don't you want him to really
know you inside out
i would agree but if you feel that
there's nothing wrong with it
it doesn't matter then you should be
sticking to what you think i've been
with 20 guys
now do you want me
and
if you if you can't say it with your
chairs maybe you shouldn't have been
with 20 guys i would agree but the one
you know yeah
i would agree but the way you guys are
placing value on body count it would
like i am my head that would make women
want to lie about it that's what i mean
like that's the women that wouldn't want
to be honest because of the value that's
placed on it well they they do lie about
it that's why it's supposed to start for
me young
yeah then you don't have to lie i've had
free yeah and you say it with your chest
no but this is what i'm saying you're
saying that
so i'm going back to her point because
she said that a man wouldn't want a
woman with
the history with a long with a long
history but i'm saying because you're
placing because our generation places so
much value on it that's what's going to
give women the tendency to lie and your
point was women wouldn't lie because
they would want to be honest with
whoever it is but because you're placing
value it's like a circle it's like we're
going around in circles
no no he's not saying that women
wouldn't lie he's saying like
now you have to live with a secret the
rest of your life like you're starting
in your marriage but yeah
yeah and so wouldn't you like yourself
want to be with someone there where you
thought you was being honest with well i
because i don't necessarily think it's
like
over for girls that have a high body
count because i ask guys this question
all the time i say okay um would you
prefer a girl with this many body like a
higher body count but she hasn't slept
with anyone you know
or i say would you rather a girl that
slept with two guys you know there's the
only other guy she slept with
and every guy every guy says hi body
count as long as i don't know him as
long as i don't know him
so so so girls can get away with it they
just move right
but like the issue is it's internal
because it hurts your ability to pair
bond and so you can't connect with the
guy you're supposed to be with as much
if you've been with like guy after guy
after guy after guy you're exchanging
energies yeah i do get what you mean but
again i feel like another assumption
i feel that is probably the case but
another assumption we're making is that
the older you are the higher your body
count is
well it's more likely yeah it is you're
going to have had it's just okay if
you're 18 or if you're 21 right
versus 35
you're gonna have had more relationships
by the time you're 35. and i know like i
know the girls
trust me i see some of my
i'm not going to name names but some of
the young this young girls these days
i'm like y'all are wild and they're
they're like they're younger than me
right but they've definitely been with
way more people than i have but it's
just
i put it like
they can't undo the damage to themselves
yeah and there's still some value in
youth so they still have like that that
youth aspect and that's valuable to a
guy
so would you say that someone that's
35 with a lower body count would be seen
as more valuable than someone that's
younger the higher body can't i don't
know that's the guys
um that's an i'd say it's an equal one
only because
someone that's young with a high body
count has youth
someone that's old with a low body count
doesn't have youth but they have body
counts so yeah it's a it's a catch 22.
but typically like women at 35 have like
the worst of both worlds like i would
say it's an exception that a girl makes
it to 35 and hasn't slept with more than
five people but you could find a girl at
21 that that hasn't done that a lot
easier yeah
just in like la in general right there's
exceptions like there's a guy in my show
that married a girl in her 30s that was
a virgin like there's exceptions it's
just not the rule
yeah it definitely is i feel like again
it just goes it it depends highly on
what the person values
in a woman
yeah hey look i'm i this is advice for
you because more so like you're a pretty
girl and more so
you'd find someone
a lot easier and better that you'd deem
high value
if you was to
vet now as opposed to
at 35
and like a lot i don't aim would be an
i just don't
agree
with because the problem with that term
left over is i feel like it's all based
on fertility like you're placing a
woman's value on her ability to have
kids
that's my problem oh it's because what
does the guy get out of the deal
like why would a guy get married most of
the time it's four kids
yeah i do i do but it's just me
personally i'm not saying there's a
problem with men doing that but me
personally i just don't think
a woman's value should be based on her
ability to have children well we can say
it shouldn't be but it is what it is
right like i don't get i don't enjoy
that you know the older i get the less
value i'm going to have
but it is what it is like i think it's
worse to ignore reality
and just hope for the best when i turn
35.
i would say it's definitely true
again like i said like me personally i
wouldn't wait till 35 to be considering
but my problem is i just don't like i
disagree with the time left over like i
i just said i'd really disagree with
that do you think it's untrue
i wouldn't say it's untrue but i
disagree with it like something so
something could be real like it's real
but i still something could be real like
this is the real life case but i still
disagree okay so so in a way you don't
disagree you agree you just don't like
it
or is it the wording
yeah you can't change that let's see
just know that's what's left over it's
the chinese thing that leftovers isn't
it left with the chinese i think it was
something in the chat should we make
merch with leftover women yeah
like left over it sounds like food like
it just sounds so derogative sometimes
the leftovers are nice but the thing is
would you want food that everybody else
has picked up yeah right i mean
would you want food that everybody else
has picked at you're hungry you see a
plate of food there and everybody's
picked it would you really go and eat it
you're hungry that's the leftovers
that's left there would you gonna eat
him speaking to the mac
you wouldn't go and eat it because it's
leftovers everybody's been at it and
that leftover food on that plate is the
woman
everybody's picked at it there's nothing
there all the chicken wings they left
all the bones left they left all the
gristle everything's there who wants it
not
not me gotta be somebody starving a hard
out
right and that's what the women are
gonna end up with we're not gonna say
you're gonna be single you're gonna end
up with somebody starving our heart up
who can do no better but eat they're
leftovers
there's men out there for women like
that
yeah but girls would rather die than
marry a betta die alone
because like they're they interviewed
women on the streets that were like
homeless
and
yeah a lot of these girls had good
relationships where they could have like
married the guy or been with the guy but
they left and ended up homeless but i'm
gonna talk more about that after i read
the super chats okay guys i
we have a lot of super chats right now
so um don't forget we're gonna turn on
members only in a second so sign up for
your memberships subscribe to the
channel and like the video right now
guys a like is free okay how many people
we got in the chat right here
1850 at the moment and only 500 likes
not even what are you guys doing a like
is free come on okay
so
matt butcher um i five dollar super chat
i feel like the girl in the green should
be a regular great example of what to
watch out for z lorenzo true or false
modern day women want the authority of
men while retaining their feminine
privilege and the accountability of
children
vincent dollicile green girl on the left
says you're going in circles no she is
the circle delusion and arguing just to
argue doesn't want to accept facts
i can't read your name feminism has
given women the audacity to tell men
what they should do naboo it doesn't
work like that neo-moses correction lime
green get some help you're confused
newbie something um lime green keeps
saying not to look at the extremes then
proceeds to constantly point out all the
exceptions to the rule the cognitive
dissonance is real sentience men also
look for young women because they don't
have the bad boy relationship trauma the
younger the woman is the more coachable
she's more coachable than an older woman
it's if you've given pookie and ray ray
the p for free then why should i pay
full price notoriously breezy less
trauma when they're younger in general
women
less trauma when they're younger in
general women look better younger more
agreeable in general less mileage not
just fertility chris a hundred dollar
super chat let's go
um
show some love to the green lady thank
you for arguing with reality it's women
like you that keep side chicks flowing
to guys like me i couldn't keep them
around without sisters like you
co-signing the lies and i tell them you
are my virtual wing woman um neo neo
moses lady in the green
you're selfish stop get help jonathan
adams the more attractive she is the
more useless she is wesley anderson my
god pearl why where did you find auntie
she's spitting opinions of some average
lime lime dream lime green is a lost
cause
um so nightmares green thinks she's the
prize at 35 and uses outlier arguments
and possibilities to ignore observable
reality i feel like you should invest in
pet food the rational oh my gosh rolo in
the chat
roll
the godfather i hope unless this is
someone pretending to be him again
is it you
i don't know no someone someone always
pretends to be him but i think this is
actually him because that person usually
doesn't donate money um kill the party
women worry men might be abusive if they
commit too early as a cope they simply
believe they have more time to find the
perfect guy than they do
dragon stallion1001 women want their own
program are the ones that are 40 not
married divorced and a cat owner smack
tagon arabs get married young in bulk
and their family structure and outcomes
look a lot better than ours marriage be
breeds responsibility and accountability
hala 29 nothing says she is rooted in
facts logic or experiences it's all
about how she feels black is panther
early marriage you attract better men
can have children earlier your body
recovers easier you lose baby fat your
children are less likely for cognitive
cognitive defects and you build more
memories with one man ryan hassan lime
green shirt when a stat proves you wrong
and then you say the stat is wrong you
have been wrong about 10 times since
i've been watching why can't you admit
when you're wrong hala 29 the girl in
green is using sign language shame
insult guilt and the need to be right
she just wants to be right but she said
but 40 times so far and i feel like 35
times opinions of some average something
green dress is answering men's
preference from a female perspective
she's not considering that we are
different we want different things
sentience i feel like i feel like
biology does not care about your
feelings
just as you are not attracted to short
fat guys
sorry
he's not fat yo
or sure
okay men are attracted to youth
fertility beauty femininity
submissiveness and fit speaking of which
guys a lot of these donations are going
to get-ish a camera i forgot to even
talk about this i appreciate that y'all
want to know what ish looks like maybe
he's short and fat i don't know maybe
yeah get it get a camera to find out men
are attracted to youth fertility beauty
submissive submit submissiveness and fit
see
sean zee no one picks up a sandwich that
10 other dudes passed up and starts
saying it's the best sandwich scarcity
creates value if men can't have you i
want you low body count
david henley girl green shirt lady no
hate for you but listen up to these
people they're exposing the lies that
society has told you and many others
women and men matt butcher not iq
shaming but the girl in the green lacks
depth of thought jonathan adams i feel
like it's not true just feelings dragon
stallion one zero zero one why would a
guy buy a used chevy instead of buying a
new ferrari women that have been ran
through versus a low body count women
young thomas it seems like she's saying
everything she's saying she's confused a
thpp network men most likely will not
want you at 35. zentians were global she
said but what men want has not changed
since the dawn of time furthermore eve
with your even with your surgeries you
look younger you are not younger
especially your uterus and your eggs you
can't fool mother nature notoriously
breezy
yellow shirt you're not even sick we see
you trying to move the goalposts listen
and respond in good faith with sense
black is panther the only thing person
that finds a woman more valuable with
ages a man she created those experiences
with she loses value to every other man
matt butcher auntie is wicked wise the
girl in green should be taking notes
please make auntie a regular guest zebra
plesso auntie knows what it means to be
an actual woman instead of a second-rate
mate jonathan adams because you feel
that way doesn't mean it's true
notoriously breezy honestly give auntie
some money and tell yellow shirt to stop
it's not the kids leaving the women
broke it's all the stupid decisions
alongside like they're kicking their
partners out of the house um big up
auntie spittin vincent dollicile um damn
auntie and the purple needs a permanent
spot on the panel i better food is
busting too you got good food that's
what
i'm
i'll
foodie just food what kind of food any
kind of food i like experimenting oh
we might we have a video idea later i'm
going to talk to you about this thp
network
please bring back the wise lady in the
back to the young ladies on the panel
the only reason that you want to be
financially stable before marriage is to
leave more easily man men see it and
understand this i see cats in their
future smack taken girl in the lime has
the real hate men vibe such a turn off
dragon stallion if the woman is cute
work somewhere like mcdonald's or a
retail store men would rather wife them
up than a cfo ceo phd because her boss
[ __ ] is a major headache david henley
purple shirt lady is awesome let's be
best friends
anger sure shepherd um women don't want
average looks because they have superman
and lois lane fantasies davis henley sex
and the city creator says she regrets
having regrets focusing on a career
instead of having kids
and now she's truly alone
uh panel thoughts
um
wait i think
that i
sorry guys i like clicked something
um
happy i feel bad for green shirt so this
is for you i hope it works out um
almighty acorns it's rare that i find a
woman worthy of my respect the woman in
purple i cannot praise your intellect
and honesty also pearl looking great
today gekko jesus
if
a people had to tattoo their body count
on their foreheads the large majority of
women would stop sleeping around vincent
dassault
girl on the green on the left says i
agree butt too much with all those butts
she could have had a bbl cormier she
thinks she does not think that a woman's
worth should be tied to fertility too
bad
her men decide
the value of women i'm sure that there
are men that think my value should not
be tied to my height in my wallet shook
two k seven pearl you're two wise and
mature for your age keep up the good
work um same age taken when you read all
the super chats we can see the can we
see the full panel
newbie says
something
lime green is conflating value as a
human and sexual market value a 75 year
old woman has value as a human but in
the sexual market her value is not there
matt butcher i feel like the girl in the
green should be a regular
um i think okay there i know there's
some in the beginning i missed um i
don't it's gonna take me a second to
pull them up because i like accidentally
refresh the page too early but the next
super chat i'll read the ones in the
beginning
but to keep the flow of the conversation
going um
do you have anything you want to say
no okay sorry sometimes they can they
can come at people
so
okay so the next question that i had
was do you feel like standards should go
up or down as we get older for men and
for women
go around for men and for women yeah
i think
standards go up for men
as we get older
because every i say everybody a lot of
people know
that um
we have to we have to earn our value
so
when we're 17 18 19 20 nobody cares
about us unless you've got game and you
just you've got it together nobody cares
um it's always women on a pedestal and
we're trying to chase them
as you get older
the tables turn
it does turn
um so things become you are
you're more together right i've got my
house got my car got this i'm stable i
you know i've come into my own i'm going
to the gym i'm working out my
lifestyle's good so we're earning that
um
but we we're saying that even getting to
35 um once you get to 35 that's going
the other way
you're going down in value
my options
are getting greater as i get older
they're not deteriorating when i was 19
17 18
nobody cared about my life
simple as that nobody cared as i got
older attention more attention more
attention as you get older as you get
wiser if you've got a lot more to offer
because i've got you know experience in
this that and for
for women that is valuable
um because that's what women are looking
for
we're not running around like 21 year
olds because
that's you know we've done it um so yeah
i think it's it's it's very clear that
as we get older men
our value goes up
and as females get older they have value
i'm sorry to say it goes down can i just
add to that before you move on to the
next person
one thing that i learned was
women
are born
with value yes and so when you hit 18
you find that
you're not allowed to go clubbing you're
allowed you people give you the kind of
pretty girl privilege access to things
they say that what a man on a boat has
worked his whole life to be on that boat
yeah he's had to go through the
financial trouble tax evasion all of
that to be on that boat
a beautiful woman aged 20 could be on
that same boat and they're in the exact
same place with him yeah they end up in
the same place and just to go one stage
deeper i've got two sons and a daughter
so where my daughter are you smiling
you've been on a boat
[Laughter]
i've been invited to zero boats
sorry i ain't got a boat yet anyway so
my dad's boat but i've got i've got two
sons and a daughter so
from very young my daughter anywhere you
go oh she's so beautiful
in the shops people on the street it
doesn't happen with the boys
do you know what i mean it doesn't
happen that's how i really recognize
that oh she's cute she's this men women
children
alike and that's where they're valued
from that my daughter's value from when
she was born my son's yeah
he's all right exactly so women are born
with value men
have to create their values most
definitely and so that's the premise
that men
will only become value as they get older
if
they work on themselves
and actually do something
if they develop if they develop if you
don't just being older isn't enough
you have to have essential qualities
yeah
um okay i feel like in terms of men you
guys are on the right track like in
terms of like men aren't
born with value like i feel like over
time
the more like knowledge you have the
more experience you have you kind of
like
you get to a point where you're able to
have options compared to like when you
are younger
in terms of women
i do understand what you're saying in
terms of um
you know women having um
value from the beginning you know people
coming up um women saying oh he's so
pretty having pretty privileged that's
definitely a thing i feel like
um i feel like over time
again um i feel like women still do have
experience like you do gain experience
over time
um i'm not going to come and lie and say
that there's not a point where
you kind of
your value becomes less in men's eyes
i'm not going to just know that we don't
value experience though yeah we don't
value experience females do it value
experience we don't
okay that's another thing as well but um
i wouldn't say
that well me but i wouldn't say it's
less i wouldn't say women become less
value
i'll just say
in you guys that
well so not personal value we're talking
about like sexual marketplace value so
like your value in the sexual
marketplace yeah then i'd say that then
then that's kind of true then if that's
the case
um
[Music]
i would say that yeah if you're talking
in terms of the sexual marketing place
then obviously is the case
because
no one would go to a man necessarily and
say he looks pretty
but i would say in terms of
in terms of
value
again i would say for both men and women
i'll say for men definitely obviously as
they age
up to a certain point their value
increases i would agree with what he
said in terms of the men
with women
i would say that
the pretty privileged thing
is stops our point so there has to be
something more than the pretty privilege
which is why i disagree with the
leftover point
ah say she just totally confused me
because if a man
when the woman is young
she's more valuable
and the older she gets sexually
but i look start going she starts
drooping everything's just going south
whereas a man
you know you start hearing about silver
fox i mean men can keep it up forever do
you not mean women just hang everywhere
the men are just always going to be
there what's over fox
leonardo dicaprio
i don't know you don't know silver fox
yeah teach us when you get old sexy
grey-haired man that's you know
look at most of the eligible men out
there you know and they're old they've
got their body together george they've
got their gray hair george clooney you
know and they look good
now look at him at his age and look at
the women at age now if we're saying
that women lose their value as they get
older and men
gain more value as they get older that's
why you're going to end up with women at
35 on their own because they're losing
value so you can't say yeah i agree with
men gain value women lose value and then
disagree against the fact that when you
hit 35
your bodies match up for most of yous
and then the men can still carry on
developing
they can still carry on that is why
no
old man wants to sleep with an old woman
no old man wants to sleep with an old
woman all the old men they want young
women because the men have still got it
and the women have lost it
is that why leonardo dicaprio
not every guy can do that
but when you when you leave men that
have the most opportunity just like to
sleep with women they always pick a
young woman
typically except jeff bezos i don't know
what you're doing man
so if you're 35 the only way you can
look good date a 70 year old you're
always going to look better than a 70
year old yeah sorry i just think it's
it's good that she made the distinction
that it's the sexual market i think
that's where the difference is if you're
basing it just on sex then
clearly then that's where the women's
value is
well and and it goes back to actually
there's going to be a large growing
there's a growing population of homeless
women in the united states because you
need 2.5 million to retire at 65. and
most women we own two-thirds of the
consumer debt
even though we make ten thousand dollars
less than men so we're not in general
good with money
and even here i know you guys have more
bailout programs but let's say they go
away tomorrow
there's going to be women that are
homeless
facts
and because you you don't and
even
the bailout programs that's how we say
that's why they say we need men because
who pays into those bailout programs for
women
if a woman gets homeless there's there's
women's shelters it's not the same
there's not men's shelters they're just
homeless like women always have a fail
safe and one day it's going to go away
and there's just going to be women who
make bad decisions that are going to be
on the streets
but this is this is why this is why
earlier i bought in history and the fact
that
there was a point where women we weren't
even allowed in education so in terms of
financially men have already had their
head start that's why i would say that
okay women they tend to be homeless
because men have had the head start from
that's why i'm saying our generation is
going to change things a lot because in
terms of women are going to be able to
catch up a lot more
so women are going to be able to catch
up a lot more um yeah i feel like we
can't ignore history when it comes to
finding when you're considering
financial the financial position of men
and women you can't ignore history i
just get totally sick of that
you know when it comes to like the
finances because i've worked in jobs
and i've earned the same as the men
and when they talk about all this pay
gap and that the men have had it and the
women have had it as far as i'm
concerned there's no reason why a woman
can't go out there and get paid the same
money for she's the same qualifier same
qualified same qualifications same job
same experience i've done it
i've done it and i've also got a pay
rise every year i've never ever worked i
had a man on the same
roll as me same experience earn more
than me so when they and you're talking
about the old generation i'm the old
generation
but what i'm trying
what sector is this transport is
management in transport okay and it
doesn't matter where it is because
wherever you go you can get paid are
these sectors you're required to have a
certain level of qualification any job
you can go any job that a man can get
qualified and get paid a woman who is
equally qualified equally experienced
and has the same manner when it comes to
working because that's what we let women
down
their mannerisms when they go in they
either go going like oh you know they're
going too strong but if you go in the
job with the right frame of mind and
nowadays the women are more qualified
from in my generation that's what you're
going to say the women are more
qualified in the old generation we
weren't that qualified and the young
generation they're qualified now so
there is no reason for people to say oh
but the men have got it now because
they've earned more that's rubbish
nowadays well especially for the new
generation because it's there for you on
the plate you've got it better than us
yeah so i don't understand like what
does that have to do with me today that
like some women were locked out of
education before i was born how does
that affect me because even in these
environments let's say
a woman has managed to get to let's say
a very senior position it's still
an environment that is dominated by
maleness
especially whites illness so for
instance if you're a white woman and
you've now come into this space you have
to overcome the barrier of being a woman
in a
male-dominated space no i don't
okay so how would you how would you
adapt you work hard
you work hard like that's what i see
like every time someone billions their
pay on the pay gap they're lazy honestly
they're lazy because the pay gap doesn't
exist when you take in this is what you
don't understand you and you take into
account personality differences between
men and women women don't ask for raises
that's the problem 60 of women have
never asked for a raise and you're going
to complain that you don't get paid the
same you don't ask for a raise that's
what i'm saying the environment a man
because this is an environment that men
have been in no it's a choice it's a
choice before women if i personally me
personally i would ask for a raise but
it's it's different because the it takes
confidence to ask for that confidence in
yourself and if you're in an environment
that wasn't even made for people like
you people like you
for some women there will be some of the
they'll be some of the first people in
that kind of environment and they have
to thrive in that you have to overcome
the barrier of having to adapt in that
environment that's something a man
doesn't have to do
one there are quotas
okay so there are specific quotas to
give women jobs over men
men don't have any quotas so we're given
they don't need it no
no because
why why do they why do we need a quota
do you not think women are qualified to
get the job on their own i didn't say
that no but that's what you're implying
by saying
no no no no no that's why i said you
can't ignore the history no because the
reason the quote is that's an excuse
that's an excuse i'm not saying it's an
excuse
anyone can go out and get any job they
want nothing's stopping us there's no
law stopping us and if anything there's
incentives i've i mean i've worked in a
male
dominated environment all my life
and i can honestly say i was the only
black woman supervisor black woman
manager
props and it never props to me it was a
job i didn't care whether i was black or
not i'm getting the money i'm getting
the same one as everybody else to me it
matter if i was black or not it was a
job and the men have got the job i've
got the job they're earning the same as
me and every year i make sure i got my
pay rise the way they did
and you didn't and i had the same
attitude you didn't make it no and the
thing is and the thing is with women i
find that when they go out like yes your
attitude has to change i'm in a male
environment i'm overloading the male so
yeah you know i mean i can hold my arm i
can have a conversation i'm going to
dress feminine but i'm going to stay my
own masculine but you see when i step
out the house and i get home to my man
all feminine
submissive
and that's what the women feel to
realize now the new generation because
you can go out there and you can do a
job just as good as a man and when you
come home you forget that you're a woman
you're still going like you're a man
that's what the men don't like
i'm i didn't i didn't everything could
insinuate i did it
i'm not insinuating i'm just saying i'm
speaking from experience because i don't
want to hear the excuse of oh because
you're a woman you've got to go in that
environment and that's a certain way
rubbish because of your color rubbish
because of your sex rubbish because of
the pay rubbish because
i've done it
and it's the norm i've done it so all
women need to do if you want to get paid
more the same way how you can speak up
and say i'm my woman this and that
speaker must say excuse me but i'm doing
pay your eyes can i have my money this
is how hard i've worked this is what i
deserve and this is what my contract
says now that's what i'm saying that now
you can do that but it hasn't always
been like that no i'm older than you i'm
53 i'm retired
so you can't say now you can do that
because i've been doing it okay but you
can't this is what i mean you can't
ignore the history okay but before you
i'm history
i'm the history
i am the history
i am 53 i am retired i am your history
so you can't tell me to forget about the
history
history and before my history my mother
done the same job as a black woman
i don't want to offend you but you can't
afford them it's not like that in every
sector it's not it's not like that if
you're talking about if you're talking
about the top sectors because they're
still for instance in if you're talking
about science if you're talking about
tech if it's all about engineering these
sectors there's still a lack of women
why because the women go and do it if
there's a lack of women go and do it i
wanted to be a bus driver there was a
lack of women you know i done i didn't
complain and said there's no room in bus
drivers go and do it they didn't have no
managers go and do it don't sit back
complaining that in these top sectors
nowadays you've got all the
qualifications you the young people you
can go university you can get degrees go
and do it you know what i mean women are
if you want to do something don't
complain about it change it like like
you said women are doing it but the
results are still not the same
women are the most educated but they
don't make more money because
they have a ton of debt and women don't
make the majority of workplace deaths
where's the equality where are the
marches men are the majority of
workplace deaths they do all of the hard
jobs therefore they get more money do
you want to be a plumber do you want to
be a bricklayer the only the only jobs
you're seeing are the the two percent of
jobs like ceos power power positions
hypothetically but my dad was one of
those top one percent ceos he worked 80
hours a week for 40 years do you want to
do that i don't most women don't they
want to have kids
okay that's again that's why i said this
is you can't you can't mix the two
because you're saying women should focus
with what you're saying you're saying
women should focus on having kids and
for that reason they wouldn't be able to
do that 80 hours a week
no i'm not saying what women should and
shouldn't do i'm saying i don't like
excuses
because you are you're blaming you're
blaming the pay gap on being a woman i'm
not blaming them you're saying you're
saying we need to be aware you're saying
you're saying we need to be aware of our
history i'm saying that has nothing to
do with me today i was born in 2022.
there's nothing that is holding me back
as a woman if anything it's offered me
advantages because all the men hiring
are attracted to you
no i that's
you you apply for a job you're a pretty
young girl most men that hire you are
going to be attracted to you to be young
again
i'll do it all again
do you not believe that oh to be young
again no no no
it's true it's true and the thing is he
you he was talking about history and uh
men had a head start it's been that way
since the dawn of time
and it's only recent that we've come
into this
this
time and and that the outcomes are
terrible this is the first time we're
changing it you know i'm a boss lady i'm
making money i'm getting the back and
look fifty percent of women are by
themselves
one in four women are and
one in four women are on antidepressants
and on top of that how can we say we
were disadvantaged before when we didn't
have to fight and worse
the men were the ones that had to go
fight words we'll save my body my choice
all day but we'll never talk about their
body their choice when they get drafted
women the majority of women didn't even
want the right to vote because it came
with the responsibility of getting
drafted so most girls are like i'm a
chill in the kitchen and i absolutely
would chill in the kitchen if that was
the same thing today that's the mindset
that that's the mindset that she had
again i wouldn't say that the mindset
that i have is the mindset of the
majority
but again like i said you can't use that
to you can't use that to just dismiss
what has happened like he said he said
men he said that men have had their head
start and it's been like that since the
dawn of time but now that times are
changing
you guys are still you are still placing
the value of women on fertility and in
the sexual marketplace i did not say
personal value i said in the sexual
marketplace okay so the men the fact you
mentioned that a man had to do 80 hours
a week why can't a woman do that then
that's what i'm asking a woman can they
choose not to
i'm telling you like i i watched my dad
work his whole life i didn't know my dad
really until i was older i barely saw
him and
i i most women would not sign up for
that they can't keep lawyers at high-end
law firms past like the age of 35
because they say screw this i have all
the money i want all i want now is a
family
they can't pay these women to stay
because after a certain age your looks
are starting to go you're what are you
doing this for after you make a certain
amount of money so again the thing
that's limiting women is
they're based off what you just said
they're personal choices and i don't
think it's limiting women
i don't so if there's nothing stopping
us from doing anything today and more
women say hey i would rather stay home
or take a lower paying job that i like
instead of doing the shitty job that all
the men are doing why is that a bad
thing
you can't say personal choice because a
man doesn't have to make that choice yes
he does that's my point a man can make a
choice of do i want to go into education
which pays less or do i want to be a
plumber that pays more you mentioned at
35 women go off and that's when they go
and start their family a man could have
had a family up until that point he
doesn't have to make that choice that's
what i'm saying no he can he can be a
stay-at-home dad if he wants to but you
can't get rid of our biological roots he
can also make that choice he could go
get a sugar mama
i mean certain men not everyone has that
not all guys can pull that off but but
you see what i'm saying he could he
could do a 50 50 relationship there's
nothing stopping us from making these
choices it's just women don't want to
work hard jobs
men do
i just think women have got more choices
now and they're just using excuses
they've got more choices than ever
they're more powerful than ever they've
got more rights more everything than
what i had in the past but what are the
outcomes
they're more unhappier than ever right
one in four women are on antidepressants
women own two thirds of the debt
even though they make less money seventy
to eighty percent of consumer decisions
are made by women when married women are
more likely to be divorced three years
after their promotion to ceo levels
compared to their male counterparts
and they divorce men 70 to 80 percent of
the time
again like i said i don't think the
mindset that i have is the mindset of
the majority of women
but again you can't dismiss the things
that are
the things that are um
limiting women from getting to that
point you can't dismiss it what is
limiting us in 2022
if i've gone and i've had a child if i
was
okay let's say for instance i was in the
middle of my degree
and i've had a child
i i'm not in the same position as a man
at all did you just wait to have the
child
okay what about the state so i
abortionately is not illegal
okay that's incorrect
it's not illegal in the u.s no i said
what about the states the states
states in general i'm not talking about
the united states i'm talking about
states in general no i'm saying you're
i'm saying in the united states abortion
is not illegal you get a car and drive
to another state that has i'm talking
about the united states i'm talking
about states in general i'm talking
about the world in general i feel like a
lot of what we're saying and a lot of
what we're discussing
is focusing on the developed world
it's ignoring because we're in the west
that's we're talking about the west
okay but i don't think we could we
should ignore the reality of so many
women i'm saying you're moving the
goalpost because we were discussing the
west and now you're saying well what
about what about the not the west but
okay okay sorry i'll talk about women
i'm talking about women generically
generically because when you're bringing
when you're talking about the debt
you're talking about all of those things
that's women in the west and those are
choices they're making
so would you would you agree there's
nothing holding back women in the west
there's nothing oppressing us history
doesn't matter because we're all born
today nothing we're cool
nothing to complain about
i would say we're not as limited as
people in the developing world that's
what i would say can i can i just say
something when she's talking about women
in the west and women in the developing
world
you can't compare the two because
they've had a choice between being a
woman in the west woman in the
developing world to develop the world
you know what men are in charge women
stay at home
raise the children look after the
animals and you know what everybody's
happy
you're lucky you might even get an
amazing marriage that you've got to
stick with and you know what you get on
with it no divorces so you can't turn
around and say about the developed world
and the western what we're talking about
in the western in the west now because
if you was in the developing world it
would be no choice and i bet
i bet there's like maybe about two
percent of divorces
in the undeveloped world than now if you
do the research they are actually
happier than we are why would be they
are happy they've got less distraction
and things are more like everybody
playing their role i'm curious what
country are you referring to when you
say the non-western world
i'm not thinking of a particular country
okay i'm not thinking of a particular
country there's just
in general i feel like everything is
focused on the western world
that's my that's my mindset and
the mindset of the women in the western
world is not the same as women
everywhere okay
go ahead that's why men that's why men
go and marry overseas because they
prefer the women
that aren't in the western world they
don't like this mindset because the
women over there they know how to cook
clean and you know take off their
husband's jacket when he comes home and
make sure everything is ready
interesting the divorce rate in india is
lower than one percent that was just the
country that i thought of that was a
good guess wasn't it yeah but people are
traveling to find wives that are a bit
more agreeable and a happy happy within
their role
so these developing countries i want to
it would have been nice to know where
you was talking about or what what
you're basing it on if you look at
where where we come from if you look at
where we come from right whether it's
the west indies whether it's africa
wherever and you look back at history
and you look back at the women then you
can't tell things were different then no
things were better then
you're like look at
in africa
india
look at everywhere and you see how it is
only here in the western world that the
women have got all this like female
power we can do we like and we're not
going to listen to men and we're okay
and then we're 35 and where are the men
during covered the women the states that
were run by women in the western world
were the states that dealt with kovat
the best you can't just dismiss women
from from positions of
leadership what do you do what do you
define as dealing with covert the best
i i can't there was articles that i read
i don't have i don't have i don't have i
don't have it with me like i can't i
don't have access to it the way you have
but if you look at i think it's angela
markle for instance
i i can't remember i don't have the i
don't have it on hand
but if you look at it um
yeah it was managed a lot better when it
was by
and that women that's actually incorrect
because remember angela merkel was she
was scare-mongering saying i'm not going
to take that vaccine and this vaccine's
all right and she actually made a big
hoo-ha about vaccines and then some
people didn't take it in germany and
some people died and that's fact
so i don't believe she did handle it
that well and the uk was better
the uk actually was quite good but
that's what it was death rate of covet
anyway it's like it's like very low
isn't it so what we're going to do with
him in the two years
that's just covered that's there's two
years that we're speaking to the mark
sorry this is two years and i've given
it as an example oh
okay and because of the history women
haven't had the chance so you can't
compare the years
you can't compare it equally because we
haven't had the chance that's what i'm
saying we've been in the workforce since
at least the 70s like that's a good time
period to look at
50 years
60 70 years
and you're quoting somebody's in charge
yeah so i'm saying like we we've we've
had the time to run the experiment of
like women in the workforce
and by and large it doesn't make women
happy
because again women that don't have a
family or children are the least happy
demographic
over the age of 45 because it's it's all
fun when you're young right like when
you're pretty you still get attention
from guys but it goes away like that
i've heard
[Laughter]
that's deeper you know but you see them
on the beach you see all the old lonely
people
you know with the wrinkly weathered skin
leathery skin with their birthday yes
they're good friends and you know with
the bikini where they have to you know
and put in the bikini
you know and then you've seen them yeah
and you know they look good females are
twice as likely to be on antidepressants
as men i can't like i see at church
when like the older ladies
with no husbands they're trying and
they're trying and you're like oh what
is this auntie doing yeah and you're
like oh
and then you deep like when we have
these conversations right and i
understand
why
how this has happened and like i'll i'll
speak to like
my mom and be like oh what happened with
her and she'll be like oh she had this
guy this guy she said no
and then like later on it was like
options like just like that
done
well and the so the one thing you
mentioned was women didn't have access
to an education but 68 of new college
applicants are women
that earlier i did mention that i said
now women are more educated right but
they don't they don't make the most
money because a lot of them get degrees
and things that are stupid
they get stupid no they do they get
stupid degrees right you're right like
how many girls are graduating psychology
marketing like degrees that means
apology yeah my
my i i wanted to do a creative degree
and my dad said no if you're if i'm
paying for it you're going to get a
degree in economics even though i would
have preferred like media or something
and my brothers all got engineering
degrees
but
the way it is now
in the us at least and here at college
is free so women are given the freedom
to give any any degree that they want
and then they pick the ones that make
less money
men work with things yeah and women was
it work
yep
and that's that's a choice
and didn't they do um survey even in was
it sweden
now where was it it was a scandinavian
scandinavian country the most balanced
country and women still chose not to do
the tough stuff to get the real money
they still wanted to do the working with
people the social work does it all about
your feelings it's all about feelings
baby
but that's their strength it's not a
it's not weird it's not a bad thing
it's not a bad thing but they're making
it look as if it's a birth thing yeah i
mean i think being emotional is like a
woman's superpower and like being able
to be empathetic and connect i think
women make like great teachers that make
great nurses they make anything with
people women thrive pediatricians
but
it's like we're in this society where we
put
money above all else where that's like
the only indicator of
of women's success but that's not it
um
okay so my next question how
old
is too old to be dating
for men and for women
i'm too loved
no i'll go
what does that mean yeah like okay
you know when someone's in the nba right
and they're playing yeah
they're going hard you know they're in
their 20s in their 30s they're chilling
at some point
people are going to look and say you are
too old to be here
you need to hang up them yeah you need
to you need to hang up hang up the
jersey okay all right
and so for men and for women how old
because i know the manosphere will talk
about men age better they do
but i think at some point too
men
in a way need to hang up the jersey i
know that's not going to be popular with
my audience but at some point like
the club lights go off so
yeah
yeah um
what age what age
you know what to be fair
let's start with the guys i think it's
different for everyone
you want to retire when you want to
retire um
i think if you've established
what you've needed
when you're coming up like so you've got
your kids
all right you know maybe a relationship
didn't work out yada yada but dating
date in what's the intention after say
50
for a guy what what what are you hoping
to get at 50
i think i'm ready to just
coronation street and just chill out and
just
you know you've got your long time
someone you know that you just survived
with and
you know you hook up once in a while but
i i don't see me
sitting at the table oh it's nice to
meet you on a date over 50. did you have
you just said
uh do you hear me no probably not but
when he hits 50. i'm just saying it for
the younger people
when he's 50 he's just looking for
someone to chill and hook up with right
and that's that older man
so when you're at 50 you're not looking
for like anybody to settle down because
you've got everything you want you don't
want anybody like over 35 you don't want
anybody your age
you want just want somebody to hook up
with yeah and if you're gonna hook up
with somebody it's gonna be somebody
younger it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
and then you can just check the chat
just have one two things
yeah but for a female
i don't know
i don't know
probably soon now
so put an age what do you could say it
put an age i'm just trying to think of
an age
you know what i i don't know i'm going
to tell you why because i don't know
what a
48 year old woman's looking for at 48. i
don't know what are you looking for like
what do you want
what are we looking for yeah maybe you
know what that's it it's a learning what
are you looking for at 50 years old i'm
not looking for nothing because i'm all
right but i know that people are out
there looking for what are they looking
for
what they can't get what they should
have been looking for at 30 and 25. okay
and i was just thinking about that
question my answer is
what age do you stop dating
every single parent when your children
leave primary school
okay
whatever age it is once your children
all finish primary school they move on
to secondary school don't bother
right because no man want no man come on
you don't mind having somebody with
kids at primary school yeah liquid
liquid but you don't want to be dating
somebody and they're like because i
heard somebody on your show saying oh
it's all right when there's a 17 year
old next door you know you don't want
that mm-hmm definitely don't worry so as
far as i'm concerned it's not the age of
the purse of the woman
it's as she's got children
when your children is primary school
don't even think about dating
just wait for old man to hook you up
right so so yeah so just grind back it
depends what where where what we're
calling dating dating
we call it what
it's almost like the question is like
when because
i think that love is a young person's
game yeah and at some point you're not
really dating like to find love anymore
it's just to find something that works
so
i'm not phrasing this in the best way
but like when
when is it just we're just gonna hook up
because we're both in the same place
looking for the same thing fine let's do
it i don't want to die alone and what
yeah so what like that's one and then
there's another point where you fall in
love you get married and have kids
when when is retirement okay right so if
i'm single and i've got no children
i'll never retire this is what i'm
saying to you okay men don't retire men
don't retire yeah they don't retire 65
70. no they don't they don't they
don't trust me they don't they still
want to pass on their legacy whether
they're going to be there for five
minutes perfect
yeah right they're out so depending on
your situation if you have a family
you've created children you've created
your legacy your children are thriving
successful then
you know you're not really looking today
you're just doing your thing
manager's doing this thing what do you
think i don't know i had a question
regarding like um
so you see the way you were saying how
well you guys kind of like encourage
women to like
marry when they're younger maybe not my
age but like
as young as possible
um what about when guys get to um
[Music]
what about when we now grow up do you
know what i'm saying like what's
stopping men from
sorry
stop it men from
looking at other women
i'll answer that one because i'm in a
long-term relationship
and i love my woman so i'm at a age
where
this person understands me
she's agreeable she's submissive
i'm not controlling her i don't do
control i don't tell you what to do but
we have an understanding you know what i
like you know what i don't like i know
you're like you know
where am i going like because there
comes a time where it's
you know another woman i don't even want
to be crude it's just another vajayjay
with another problem and issues that i'm
not prepared to deal with
so i'm just doing my thing i'm just
making sure that i'm into the mic sorry
i'm just making sure that i'm thriving
i'm trying to be successful for me and
my family because that's now my family
and i'm responsible for them all you
know so
that's
that's kind of
if you're giving your man what he needs
and his understanding i think
you know you
you should be all right but it depends
on what level of man you're looking for
so if you're looking for this mr high
value
you know i've got money i jump on jets
i've got a business call i'm gonna be
spending the night in toronto then
you know what you're gonna get well
that's why some girls like nba wives
they know their men are cheating they
know he's got five sides
and i don't feel bad for any of them
like that girl that was dating jason
derulo
and she wanted to come out and cry
because jason derulo cheated on her what
did you think you were gonna get
you dated jason derulo even even ugly
face wayne rooney
he was with the old woman prostitute
the old woman is mrs still there he's
been found numerous times
high value he is he generates millions
even though he's not even playing
football anymore she's not going nowhere
wish again
she she knows what the deal is women
will stay over for legacy
right they understand right i'm creating
legacy see my children them just being
rooney
yeah opens doors for them yep
and and they're looking for that's what
women are looking for you're looking for
the prize to breed
your children to be successful and be
you know well that's why the the
you know being a single mother is like a
woman's mating strategy because she gets
the the genes from the first guy and
then she gets the parental investment
from the second guy
there you go so it's like a mating
strategy
so what age
after all that
so
the age to like stop dating um
i'd say for men
i do agree in terms of that there's
become a point where it's like okay you
may have like all the money and all that
kind of stuff but it's kind of like
uh
um i'd say for men like
maybe like 45
you would i would date a 45 year old
you're 21 right i probably wouldn't have
about 20 yeah yeah 21. but it's kind of
it's kind of weird there's a weird thing
that happens at like 23 to like 26 where
you're like our dad's hot
like it's over it's a really weird phase
but i promise you it'll happen one day
because when i was 21 when i heard a guy
that was 30 i was like oh grow like i
can't do 30. and then now i'm like i
could do 45 like that's fine
i don't know i don't maybe i haven't
reached that point yet but um
yeah i don't know i say for men like 45
because personally i wouldn't date
someone that's 45 years old that's way
too old for me but um
women
when do you stop dating
um
what would i say i'd say like
we're 45 so what are women going spit it
out
i know um i'd say
i'd say like
i said 40
40 okay okay yeah
i can't put an age on both of them i
can't put an age on it
okay 60.
too old to be there it's just like why
would you stop dating like if you
haven't found your personal world you
still
i'm saying for love like when is love
off the table
i don't know if i believe in love i
don't know if i believe in love i think
it's just a
compromise
regardless of what age i think it's a
compromise
i don't know about love
okay what do you think
i'm just sure that's so sad i believe in
love
um
yeah i said what i thought about primary
school once you've got kids once they
got pregnant once you've got kids at
primary school then once they've left
stop dating because there's no point but
if you're single you've got no children
okay
prettier yeah
for men oh you said no oh men they can
go on forever never never
um i think
men
at the age of
i'm gonna say 60 for men
i i'd give you 60. yeah i give you 60.
as long as you're like
in shape you've got your [ __ ] together
yeah 60s a good time to
if you're not in a long-term
relationship
yeah but women
and we're talking about love we're not
just talking about any random thing
we're talking about you start looking
i'd say about like
yeah this is topping it
[Music]
like we're talking about like this woman
hasn't been in a relationship so she
hasn't got like
yeah single single yeah widowed
no no no widow oh no we're there okay
then
sing one of the 50 of women that are
single and childless over 30
yeah maybe maybe 40 yeah maybe you'd say
40 for women i'm going to say 40.
yeah maybe
that's what i would say 35 32
okay i'll give you i give them like
now i reckon they could still have it at
33.
oh no no no no
visualizing something no i am i'm
literally like thinking of examples
yeah that'd be tough yeah nice tougher
yeah it's tough for women
so knowing that the average age of first
marriage is 31 how would you put that in
the uk
because you said you said 30 right yeah
with the average age of first marriage
do you think most women aren't in love
with the person that they married i
think they just married the first person
that lost them after 30. really yeah
and they're so clever the women are they
can convince the man that it's all for
real and
yeah men will go for it by that time a
woman's got her act together and she can
convince a man with a womanly wiles
yeah
and do they do you know what i mean
you can convince a man and you think
aren't you yeah yeah
do you think do those women like divorce
the guys later i think they would yeah
is that what you've seen typically yeah
they would oh if they don't the men just
go and they have um
a harem and do their thing other women
and it's quite acceptable in in some
cultures for the man to go off and have
a woman and be married and stable home
life and have another
family elsewhere
would you if you were to meet someone
that you like i know you're not actively
dating but if you were to meet someone
would you be open to it
like to dating or getting married to
someone
oh i'm not um i'm off the market but
yeah yeah oh i thought i thought you
said that
not single okay
no so i was curious would you do you
feel that way about cheating like are
you okay with like sharing a guy
i think that you called it cheating soul
cultures wouldn't oh sorry i think
that's where it is and i think if it's
called if it's called cheating
then yeah i think i have a problem with
it but
if it's
acceptable and it's okay and everybody
knows about it and it's open why not
it's been happening for years centuries
and histories and it's worked i'm sure
we've all got aunties and uncles
somewhere you know they're happily
married and they got their family then
you go somewhere else and it's like
who's that and it's like oh he's got
another family but his wife knows about
it and everybody knows about it and and
it works you find that at the funeral
yes
[Laughter]
what about you guys have you ever been
cheated on
no no have you ever been cheated on
would you ever overlook cheating to get
the guy that you wanted if he had
everything that you wanted
and you knew it wasn't like you're the
only one that he was in love with
yeah i would really if really speaking
to mike realistically speaking yeah i
probably would yeah
okay what about you
i'm not sure i see cheating as a act of
betrayal that's how i see cheating but
there's instant like there's
particular scenarios where it's just one
time or
yeah there's exceptions but
i don't i can't say unless i was in the
situation
yeah i mean i would have a hard time
with it to be honest like my
i i don't know if i could get past that
to be honest um
but i understand like the concept that
like it's very common in a lot of
cultures
um okay i'm gonna read some super chats
guys you already know what we're super
chatting for
get
ish a camera hashtag
hashtag it in the chat get issue camera
also a like is for you guys i see we
have a thousand likes on the video
there's two thousand of you in here i
really think we should get to what do
you think a thousand two hundred one
thousand two hundred makes sense yeah i
think i think we can do a thousand two
hundred before i'm done reading these
super chats so
also subscribe to the channel um right
now we're in members only mode if you
guys want to become a member at the ten
dollar tier you guys can get an
exclusive vlog um we have another vlog
that we're dropping this week as well
and at the five dollar tier you can be a
part of the chat we also have a discord
server at i believe the 10 tier which
the link isn't working we're fixing that
this week though but but yeah you should
join because this week we are dropping
the discord server okay
so
um debo 45 4735
better at what age do you start dating
with intent stefan or tiz sparta became
a gynocentric social order society over
time because the men were always
training and fighting when rome came
over it took over the gynocentric
society
jc torres question for the ladies
do women respect taller men and do men
respect a woman with
do women respect taller men and do men
respect more a woman with a nicer body
like a big butt
okay i'll ask that
do men respect a girl with a big butt
more
i thought that about respect i like
one yeah okay do you guys respect tall
man more than short man
probably yeah
um yeah
no i just think it's all in his map now
his personality puts himself over
i think
for the
what was the question the boat the black
thing men will allow
things to happen that they wouldn't
necessarily allow if she there's pretty
privilege yeah she gets she gets away
with more of the hotter shoes exactly
yeah
okay house of has men as long as the
knee and back work to smash for a woman
as long as she dusts off the old eggs
and writes a 90 000 ivf check old women
equals future babysitter oh we didn't
even cover that that's that's a good
because ivf is so expensive zmj girl
bosses modern women you are not the
minority anymore you have been fighting
you don't know y'all won most of the
battle you're going to turn at 35 and
destruction is behind you bravo house of
house don't worry pearl when you're 35
you'll still get attention from us for
green she is suffering from liberal
feminist indoctrination victim always
nightingale 21 super chat thank you um
lori darylan 87 in the usa if you were
if you live where abortion is illegal
like oklahoma you can drive to colorado
where it's legal until the moment of
birth so what about that it's legal in
colorado till the moment of birth
i had
a bit late look like it hurt you
oh that's nuts okay
paradox two dollar super chat marcellus
d the
invention women's tampon made it easier
for them to get to the workforce um matt
butcher i feel like the lime girl won't
be coming back but you could find a 12
year old to take her place the same
train of thought paradox two dollars
super chat marcellus d she keeps
speculating you can't dismiss but have
any but doesn't have any data to prove
it um david henley m thatcher said the
feminists hate me don't they i don't
blame them i hate feminism it's poison
let's remember history um the green
shirt brett cormier take away all of
lime green's excuses show would be half
as long but twice as informative she's
hearing words but not comprehending
meeting maybe her ears don't work and
facts prove her wrong and and on my the
304 demand choices then presented with
said choices go full victim mode don't
or keep cooking these 304s granny don't
keep deep fry that pickle michael green
shirt is so brainwashed he's given all
the facts and evidence and refuses to
believe it
mighty almighty acorns one of you guys
with these names almighty acorns like
how do you think of that
i i bend the knee to the queen on the
left pearl she is the best female guest
you've had in months show these girls
out here what integrity is samuel uda i
find it funny that light green is
complaining about not enough women in
the top sectors when she doesn't want
more women to be road bin workers or bin
collectors dash token e30 many women
spend more time looking in the mirror
instead of using that time to study how
to make money women want cushiony jobs
not gritty ones dan digger
women are crushing men in the career
field right now with less work and less
qualifications because of quotas it's
causing animosity in the workplace and
driving a huge wedge in our culture john
gq kevin samuel's goal was for older
generations of women to speak to the
younger generations of women on this
subject and here we are seeing this play
out kevin our vincent dolcile listen
green girl listen to auntie she will
lead you through the underground
railroad to success auntie's martin
knows what she's saying unlike you
caesar is one zero zero one light green
is gonna start saying the stone age is
preventing her from getting a job
mr missing ned
imagine competing for higher wages in
the job you are in no the manager should
make it easier for women to get ahead
vincent docile like green girl wants to
play victim and ignoring auntie's good
advice she thinks she knows better than
60 years of experience she'll be alone
and a victim dragon stallion one zero
zero one neon green woman hattie green
was nicknamed the richest woman in
america in the 1890s and she was the
wall street street financer financier
quit blaming the times instead of
laziness samuel udot it's clear that the
women in the light green has a victim
mentality it's clear that you've got a
lot of healing to do shout out to the
queen and the dark green for having an
open mind and now and listening to
understand not to respond alex our non
20 super chat thank you derek spin a
lime green shirt stop being hard-headed
i know you're 21 but you're getting free
game listen up i feel like you will buy
a dog and die and i'll die alone modern
women live in a clown world
blue collar henry women traded their
husbands for the government program so
instead of being submissive to one now
you're submissive to an entire
government so good job happy i feel bad
when i see these attractive and
interesting young women who got
absolutely housed hosed by feminism
sitting there confused stressed and
fearful when 50 years ago they would
have had a couple kids and be content
caesar one zero zero one society accepts
low value women low value men are
treated like crap derrick spina you
can't make this stuff up der dasir you
should talk about how the uk law women
can't great men the definition doesn't
even allow it even if coerced or under
the threat of violence it's still
classed as essay and not grape that's
pretty vile i did not know that that's
crazy jay dahl
i see the women disagreeing with the
left over but we
know that a man can't provide a leftover
man
we know that a man that can't provide is
a leftover man we accept reality but
women don't men
around the world haven't changed it's
western women who have changed happy i
feel bad for the green shirt so this is
out to you good luck hope it works out
um almighty acorns i find it's rare i
found a woman that's worthy of my
respect the woman the purple i cannot
praise your intellect enough also pearl
looking good today
um okay i'm gonna go back to the bottom
where okay
the
beginning so okay thomas denman is japan
christmas eight
is japan christmas cake age equals
leftover woman notorious breezy this is
for auntie she's spitting big fats these
girls just need to listen to wisdom the
best girls are getting locked off in
their early to mid 20s valsal docile i'm
here
i'm here giving communion for auntie's
purse here's a few dollars taylor
russell you don't find yourself you
create yourself a long a man
matt butcher if i hear i feel like one
more time um dragon stallion one zero
zero one for the ladies on the couch men
do not want to wife up a promiscuous
woman a boss [ __ ] masculine any energy
or a woman that already has kids
notorious breezy ladies get to know
yourself quickly because biology will
catch up to you and you will die alone
you do not have the time you think you
do you don't have time to be doing up
professional girl fun dragon stallion
one zero zero one lady in the purple
giving knowledge and wisdom question is
will the woman on the couch take it to
heart um nightingale ten dollars for ish
get that man a camera let's go
marcus moore ladies would you rather
have a high profile job that makes
oh that's a good question i'm gonna ask
that in a second um vincent dassault
luke luke cage is in the corner
spinnings backs green girl number two on
the couch needs to pay attention he's
giving her free games that'll help her
if he listens love auntie red pill
dropping some winston here vincent
dassault girl number green girl number
one on the couch you're trying to school
auntie on marriage is insane you know
everything listen from someone you don't
know everything listen from someone
who's been there basmal 35 i want to
make children with a woman who's pretty
pleasant and faithful that's worth way
more to me than raising another man's
kids for a woman who's strong
independent and don't need a man room a
great choice pearl keep bringing that
gray-haired wisdom to shut this
foolishness down i don't think these
girls get that it's time to hush and
listen to your goddamn elders can't
going there can't tell been there
nothing
black is panther the child in the green
neon is a major distributor of drug
knows known as copium primarily
used by 304s to cope up with their
delusions matt butcher i feel like the
green
the girl with the green shirt lives in a
fantasy world maybe she thinks life is
like the movies um she is lost so there
is a question
would you rather
have
a high profile job that makes twenty
thousand dollars a year
or
i can't or a low
i can't find it oh my gosh
it was
one second
okay i can't find it but it's basically
would you rather have a high profile job
that makes twenty thousand dollars a
year
or work on an oil rig
in alaska that makes two hundred fifty
thousand dollars per year
i'm going to alaska you're going to
alaska so long family it's been nice
knowing you
um when you say high profile job what
whatever your dream job is
for 20k a year yeah
maybe like a social media influencer
you've got a high clout
like it's easy living but you're getting
20k yeah
maybe getting flown out all of that good
stuff
you're comfortable you're comfortable
like you're comfortable
um
yeah i'd pick that
yeah okay
uh
me personally when i'm looking for a job
it's a it's a mixture between it's a
balance between fulfillment and money
so whichever one would fulfill me more
okay so the 20k yeah
what was the second how much does it say
oil rig 250k oil rig in alaska
auntie you know we're there together man
i'll take they'll worry yeah you know
we're going to just get away from
everybody
ish what are you taking i'm taking the
oil right
see i would i would take the 20k a year
but it but it's it how come
because i'll meet off my dad before i
take that child
sorry dad um but
but um and i just think i would
i find a 50 year old get married like
if i didn't have my dad like i would
i just could not see myself being happy
being in an oil rig
and
but but it's interesting because three
out of the four women like this this is
demonstrating the pay gap in real time
because three out of the four women said
oh no we're picking fulfillment over
money where both of the men said i'm
picking money over fulfillment
not even a second fall yeah i'd go for
it i'd go for the oil rig yeah i don't
mind the hard work because you know what
you're getting at the end of it yeah you
ain't gonna have to do it forever i
ain't gotta do nothing else yeah you
just make your money and you're out
there so you're not really spending any
money while you're there
everything's being paid for you
oh you might have just i'm just thinking
your wages will just be untouched i mean
how much are you going to spend on
another you're actually you might have
that's what i'm saying one's hiring i am
here
well rick
yeah because the outlays are going to be
small
you're going to get fed on the lower rig
you know everything's there that's it
they have to buy anything but here's the
caveat that i put to you i feel like
you've lived life to an extent right and
so
you there's not much to fulfill on your
side so making that money makes sense
for you
yeah do you know what i mean well being
away from people makes sense to me as
well okay i heard that yeah definitely
hear that
um do you guys care i'm curious
a blue collar guy or a corporate guy
does it matter to you
blue collar what do you mean by that
like a guy that's working as like a
plumber electrician garbage man or
versus someone that's working in
corporate america who would you rather
date speak into the mic please
um
no i don't really for me personally it
doesn't really matter it doesn't matter
i don't have a preference in terms of
the two things he said i don't have
preference
don't worry i think i'd go for the blue
collar
i do too actually i think i'll go for
the blue color because that's more on my
level and we can build together
i'll do the blue color well they're
always more like masculine guys in those
jobs i've just found i blew jobs and
paint jobs and not only that i think
they're going to be around more
yeah
after especially after around after what
pearl said about how long her dad worked
you know that's what i'm thinking the
hours
yeah i want him at home plus those guys
don't know how to quit like even my dad
that's funny i called him yesterday and
i was trying to talk to him and he's
like i gotta go i'm busy i'm like dad
you're retired
easy yeah yeah yeah yeah he can't they
they yeah they can't ever shut it off
i'm like what what are you dad you're
busy you're not busy doing anything but
you still gotta wake up at four o'clock
in the morning four five o'clock in the
morning yeah yeah well he doesn't get up
that all right anymore he doesn't
okay how much do you guys think that
submission costs
so so i always hear that girls say they
need the right leader to be feminine and
submit to a guy like they can't just be
feminine and submit to anyone
so at what income do you need a guy to
make to submit to him and trust his
judgment
and what do you and
like the reverse of this guy's point of
view do you think there should be a
minimum that girls should
submit to money-wise yeah
yeah
this is a question kevin samuels always
would ask
you see the thing is
um speaking to the mac yeah the thing is
it depends in in where i'm at
so
am i earning more than you if i'm only
more than you if i if you're on
eighteen thousand a year and i'm 22 then
i'm the guy
you know it i i don't think there's
i believe
that
it it's in you or it's not
am i either masculine or i'm not you're
either feminine or you're not and if you
are feminine the masculine guys will
find you and they will want you
and
if you're
so i don't know i don't think it's a
money thing i think it's
because for me
you could be a ceo and then 250
and i could earn 50. like you're not
batting me up like that i'm still gonna
back you up i'm still king of the castle
like and
i've i've seen that play out um it's
just you are who you are i can't become
submissive because you make more money
than me i'm not gonna do it it's just
not it's just not in my dna so i i don't
know i don't
i don't think
money
i can't
quantify it so so devil's advocate here
right if i'm thinking i'm gonna trust
the leadership of a guy that i'm dating
right and where i'm trusting him to make
the decisions and obviously i have to
vet the guy yeah and so when they say
that submission costs i think a lot of
times like it's misconstrued where what
women need mean is we need a competent
leader right and it's not the bomb right
so at some point at some point
it's hard to quantify because we can all
think of someone that maybe doesn't make
a lot of money but is very competent
yeah but in general like there is a
point where there is a point yeah there
is a point but um
fro from a female's perspective
perspective i'd be looking for like is
he solid he's solid he does his own
thing
he don't ask nobody for nothing and he
just keeps it moving he's
self-sufficient
he's he's self-sufficient and
you know i've always been
self-sufficient so i don't need nothing
from you so you want to give me
something so as long as you're right
he's holding a steady job
he does a job at the very least yeah and
yeah yeah and he doesn't have any debt
and he doesn't have any debt and he's
not making stupid decisions
okay
what about you and do you actually
question from a guys do you think if a
girl makes a lot of money and she's very
competent that she should be able to
submit to the average guy even if she's
more competent than him
i
i don't know okay the thing is i don't
think they will
but i think
it depends on the guy like if if we meet
up and that's your that's how you do i'm
we're just gonna bump heads until one
submits and it ain't gonna be me so
if it's going to be you then we can work
and sometimes it does take that for i'm
not going to say all the time sometimes
it does take an alpha male to just like
make an alpha female know her place
sometimes
but yeah it's either in you or it's not
okay what do you think
um how much it would take to to submit
to a guy
um
kind of backing off from what he was
saying um
it'd have to just depend on how you are
as like
you can be making millions of
pounds and whatnot and not be smart with
your money do you know what i'm saying
um
but then again you can have
that much money to win it to a point
where even if you are stupid with your
money it's not really going to go
anywhere do you know what i'm saying so
um
i'd say
for me to be submissive
number one i have to respect you first
and foremost and respect like your
decisions and everything like that um
i don't know i i wouldn't say i'd put a
price on it
okay but respect i i'm not gonna lie and
say i wouldn't respect someone that's
making more than me
to an extent like if you're making more
than me have some sort of respect for
you but yeah you could be making more of
me and i've not be right with your money
but i'd have to respect you first and
foremost but i'd say
yeah i don't know
there's not really a prize
would you so it's like roughly just
being able to take care of himself have
his own place have like that sort of
thing yeah would you submit to a guy
that lives at his mom's house
is he paying the rent
yeah um let's let's say no
no okay what about you
um
is it permanent
um
no i'm saying what income so the first
question is what income
i i agree with her in terms of i
wouldn't put a price on it okay and i
feel like
like i said relationship is compromised
with the mic sorry
[Music]
relationship is compromised and
yeah to compromise there's a bit of
submission required on both parts that's
what i would say
i oh actually in the the mom's house
does he have to be paying rent at the
mom's house for you to submit
let's say he's been living there for two
years
i think i would still submit again
depends on the situation like is he
saving money to buy a house versus is he
just living there to live there yeah
yeah
yeah
and it depends on my own situation as
well
yeah
okay what about you i've never
dated anyone that's earned more than me
okay and i've always been submissive no
problem
okay but it's got to be
responsible it'll be a man yeah
yeah it's gonna be a man do you agree i
think a lot of guys can if
even if a guy makes less money if he's
overly masculine like i think he can get
like i think masculinity gives guys a
lot of points especially in like today's
day and age where the men i think
struggle with masculinity more than ever
yeah my mind's hot
he's very messy
i actually got um
got cussed on i think something sarah
said once and i
said that i was on holiday and i had on
the shorts shorts like short shorts and
a little top and i was at home and
somebody made a comment
a man made a comment towards the way i
looked i happened to mention it to my
man who was in england at the time
and he said what were you wearing he saw
us he goes but there's men around the
house you're too old to be wearing stuff
like that that's all right then i
changed and i got rid of it all and i
was told that
i was whipped and i was like my man's
telling me that i'm dressed in
appropriately so i've changed my clothes
well i supposed to listen to a woman but
they seem to think that because i was
earning more than him
but he's the head of the relationship so
you don't need no man girl that's what
they think
okay i'm going to read super chats and
then i think we're going to close out
the show
so um think of any like final thoughts
you want to say because i'm going to
give everyone the michael one last time
but i'm going to read the super chats
first so guys thank you so much for all
the super chats i'm thank you for the
new members in the chat thank you for
all the donations to get ish a what
um like this video i think we have 2 000
people in here and we hit 1 200 likes
can we hit 1003 before the end of the
stream come on like this video okay
almighty acorns a man's acorns should be
worshipped by his woman submit to god in
the man as christian
submit to the god and the man as
christians would say that's where my
name comes from
oh that's interesting actually um ryan
reynolds some ruthless dudes sorry green
shirts don't worry just take advice from
pearl maybe we
mean but definitely take the message
samaya and tegan sister and lyme don't
be hardheaded taking the advice feminism
really
makes woman so bitter shout out to the
man in the purple as he was spitting
pure facts
kai zoku dark green is bad tell her to
hit me up she if she wants to be
submissive and ride a boat
andrew
do you want to date a guy with a boat
i'll take that as a yes
what's your what's your ig
um she can plug it in a second
she'll plug it in
okay andrew edwards black dress pearl
what's your ring size marcus moore
ladies would you rather have a high
profile job that makes 20k or clean suit
sewers for 100 okay i i did i did a
close one that was the actual question
um
night and gale get that man a camera
let's go
sir deborah four seven three five better
at what age do you start dating with
intent oh let me refresh it because i
think that was
earlier
um okay
i am just jules late on the paycheck
up late on the playback i like the lady
in purple some age can give us some more
insight black is panther hashtag get is
just step stool
yo
shout out to me
yeah like it he's he's like five foot
let's say six foot seven
exactly every day he switches
okay i'll maybe almighty acorns a man's
acorn oh should be worship get issue
steps okay i think that's all the super
chats
so um why don't we go around give your
final thoughts tell the people where
they can find you
and yeah anything you want to say
final thoughts
stay here
subscribe
like our videos this this channel is
going to go a long way
um yeah so just
i i just think people should just take
advice from everyone around talking
about yeah you haven't you haven't got a
believe everything but there's
someone's got something so i've learned
something from you lot you've learned
something from me whether we agree
disagree there's something
but um yeah you can find me at the gym
rat pack just put in the gym rat pack
does entertainment um i'm there with the
boys
um and
paul thanks for having me on the show
man
thanks for coming no worries
um final thoughts
i feel like i've kind of like
with everything that we've been talking
about i'm kind of not i wouldn't say i'm
in between two heads but i'm like
learning i wouldn't say i have a set
mind on how i am when it comes to
certain things but it's like i'm kind of
open
to like different kind of things but
yeah um
thank you for having me and you can get
my socials make the creator
on everything and send a picture of the
boat yeah yeah and yeah
and the submission will follow
yeah
thank you for coming
um yeah i'll say thank you for having me
and
yeah i guess my views are too
controversial
um
but yeah i think i will take some things
from
[Music]
jenny yeah i'm sorry auntie jenny has
said
oh sorry i will take some
i will take some things from what rt
jenny said um and yeah thanks for having
me yeah thank you for coming and thanks
for having me i just want to say don't
worry about the
what people are saying you're still
learning and you're still young all i
got to say is
hang out with
get advice from older people
grandparents old aunties and men
any men in your life
i recommend all the young people get
especially young women get advice from
your elders and from men and make more
male friends that you can rely on that's
when you find out about men from men men
that are not trying to smash you yeah
yeah that's a caveat
i think so
that goes
men and women can't be friends
but they're they're beautiful where are
they gonna find guys that don't want to
hook up with them
brothers and uncles yeah
yeah you know the uncle's out there when
they're trying to you know yeah oh my
goodness no those aren't tools yeah
good luck
um i think there was one or two more
super chats
so guys um like the video i saw you guys
get to one three can we get to one four
i know i'm asking a lot can we get to
one four likes the only reason i'm
asking is because for real it really
helps with the algorithm that is the
first thing youtube registers is you
guys liking the video so it was so
important to push these streams out okay
i am just jules
late on the playback i like the lady in
purple some age can give some insight
blackest panther again hashtag get isha
step stool guys help him reach the
counter help him reach the counter
there's another one i've just seen um
garden c ish is the mic check king
my guy i appreciate you um all mighty
acorns oh i did that one there's another
one did you that was it
okay okay yeah no two step stool
donations today
okay guys thank you so much for watching
um you already know we could not do it
without you thank you so much for the
super chats we will be getting issue
camera hopefully end of this month
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
like the video on your way out sign up
for our memberships while you're at it
go like our facebook page because that's
new and our twitch page is also new and
we will talk to you next time bye
yeah i'll go